und leute
Ja
Wir haben nichts super high IQ mäßiges soviel kann ich euch sagen
Wir haben heute keine Gehirnzellen mehr übrig high IQ kram zu machen
Ich kann heute ein bisschen schwätzen, ein paar Sachen ein paar Fragen beantworten im Chat
über aktuelle Ereignisse reden, keine Ahnung, vielleicht ein paar YouTube Videos gucken
aber ich kann heute weder was programmieren noch was basteln noch was anderes noch Linux
Zeug machen
Der Account ist gesperrt
Warum ist der Account gesperrt
Hä?
Warum ist der gesperrt
Ich hab ihn gestern gemordet, warum sollte er, ich hab da keinen gesperrt
Hä?
Warum sollte er gesperrt sein
Hab ich irgendwie, hab ich irgendwas verkehrtes gemacht
Mountain, du Dankeschön für den Zap
Den gibt's nicht mehr
Gestern gab's den noch
Hä?
Warum ist sein Account gesperrt
Der war doch gestern noch im Stream, was hat er denn angestellt
Vielleicht war es doch keine so gute Idee ihn zu modden
Wer weiß, wer weiß was er angestellt hat
Hat er irgendwas im Discord gesagt oder so
Ich mein irgendwas, der hat eigentlich nicht den Eindruck gemacht als ist es irgendwie
der zweite Chainlord der laufend gebannt wird
Ich hab keine Ahnung, okay
Muss man nicht verstehen
Ich bin jetzt auf Microsoft, ich bin jetzt auf Windows 11, ja aber schon seit ein paar
Monaten
Schon seit Dezember
Gestern war er aber im Stream, gestern war er im Stream
Also keine Ahnung was er getrieben hat
Vielleicht wurde der Account gehackt oder so
Ich glaube, wir machen zur Sicherheit mal unmod
Man weiß ja nie was da los ist, erst wenn er wieder auftaucht wird er wieder gemoddet
Invalid Username, okay er ist eh schon unmodded
Anscheinend kann man Accounts, also gestern Abend war er noch nicht gebannt
Weil da konnte ich ihn noch modden
Interessant, so Moment ich muss mal kurz die Kirby Musik ein bisschen runterfahren
Ist mir gerade leicht minimal zu aufdrächtig
Ja, das geht immer
Da hat er heute Nacht irgendwas angestellt, keine Ahnung
Wer weiß, wer weiß was da wieder gelaufen ist
Poggers und wie lief's?
Kampeng Poggers Subscription
Hast du Ahnung von Elektrotechnik?
Kommt drauf an, auf welchem Niveau man Ahnung haben muss für die Frage, die du stellen
willst
Sollte bestanden haben, oh das hab ich mir auch schon manchmal überlegt und hab's dann
verkackt
Aber ich will dir jetzt da nix einreden, dass du dir Gedanken machst oder so
Du wirst es schon am besten wissen
Ja gut
Heute war wieder richtig sinnlos, sag ich euch
Halbtag gemietet, falls jemand mein letztes Video gesehen hat
Dazu, das da
Dazu gab's heute bei mir auf der Arbeit Retrospektive
Wo sich darüber ausgetauscht, also eigentlich nennt sich das nicht Retrospektive
Sondern Ursachenanalyse oder sowas
Also quasi eine Art Retrospektive
Und wir haben ohne Scheiß, wir haben 45 Minuten erzählt, ob der Plan, der Ablaufplan der Ereignisse
korrekt ist, auf die Minute genau haben die dann nachgeguckt, wer wann wie welche Mail
geschrieben hat
Und irgendwann hab ich dann gesagt, also wir sind ja hier eigentlich in der Ursachenanalyse,
aber was ist denn jetzt eigentlich genau die Ursache gewesen
Also so wirklich schlaut raus geworden bin ich noch nicht, ich hab mir da ein paar Sachen
zusammen gereimt
Aber es gibt nicht so wirklich rundes Bild
Ja und dann kam raus so wirklich wissen, was eigentlich jetzt genau kaputt war tut auch
keiner
Nee
Nee nee
War tatsächlich gar nicht, haben sie auch gar nicht versucht
Ok, habe folgende Rgb Strip
Kann man das aufmachen?
Muss ich das grad mal checken
Moment, das sind Reflinks
Logan meinst du, wir merken das nicht, dass du irgendwelche Reflinks verschickst?
Wobei, ja doch, das sind Reflinks, oder?
Wahrscheinlich Reflinks
Ich kann das mal ohne Reflink aufmachen
Ist schon sehr vertrauenswürdig, vertrauenswürdiger Hersteller
Wenn ich das, wenn ich das schon höre
Jun Sa Sa Ach du Scheiße man, wie soll man den Hersteller
aussprechen?
Jun Sa Xi Fra Ge Leck
Was?
Jun Sa Xi Fra Frag Ge Leck oder so
Ach du kacke man, was soll immer das sein sollen
China-Chinesen Kram wahrscheinlich
Ja höchstwahrscheinlich China-Chinesen Kram
So und was ist deine Frage?
Deine Frage ist
Laut Datenplatz soll der Strip mit 30 bis 90 Watt betrieben werden
Kommt mir ein bisschen viel vor
Hab ein 15 Watt Netzteil und funktioniert trotzdem
Wenn ich jetzt ein 50 Watt Netzteil anschließe
Kann ich mir sicher sein, dass dann nicht, dass er nicht durchbrennt
Tja, nachdem es der billigste RGB Strip
Lass mal kurz gucken, ist das überhaupt realistisch, ob das Ding so viel braucht?
Wie viele LEDs, oh das ist ein ganz enger
Ach doch, doch das kann schon so sein
Allerdings, du musst dir keine Gedanken machen
Hast du mal gemessen, wie viel Strom da aktuell
beziehungsweise wie viel Leistung der wirklich zieht?
Hast du mal was angeschlossen, was das misst?
Es könnte nämlich durchaus sein, dass du erstmal gar keinen großen Unterschied merkst
Ob 15 Watt oder 50 Watt Netzteil
Je nachdem, wie es ist
Weil, diese Spitzenlast ziehen LED Strips eigentlich nur
Ist ein bisschen laut, oder?
Nee geht eigentlich
Die Spitzenlast ziehen LED Strips eigentlich nur, wenn du sie komplett weiß stellst
Volle Helligkeit weiß
Warum weiß, ist eigentlich auch ganz logisch
Die Dinger haben ja drei bis vier kleine Lampen drinnen
Pro Pixel, nennen wir das mal, oder Pro LED
So ein LED besteht aus drei bis vier kleinen Lämpchen
So nenne ich es einfach mal aus drei bis vier kleinen Lämpchen
Also einmal RGB, und dann eventuell noch weiß
Und wenn du den LED Strip auf weiß schaltest
Dann werden halt alle LEDs volle Pulle
Angemacht
Und dementsprechend braucht der bei weiß mit voller Helligkeit eben den meisten
Die meiste Leistung
Dementsprechend, wenn du was anderes eingestellt hast
Als volle Helligkeit und weiß
Kann es durchaus sein, dass du gar keinen Unterschied siehst zwischen 15 und 50 Watt
Netzteil
Weil der eh grad gar nicht so viel verbraucht
Das heißt, du müsstest mal was anstöpseln
Und mal gucken, was der überhaupt mit dem 15 Watt Netzteil zieht
Ob du denn überhaupt ein dickeres Netzteil brauchst
Dass der abfackelt, das glaube ich ehrlich gesagt eher nicht
Dass das 50 Watt ziehen kann und mehr
Bei voller Helligkeit ist durchaus möglich
Ist durchaus möglich
Ich meine, das sind 144 LEDs pro Meter
Das ist ziemlich dicht
Das braucht schon ein bisschen Strom
Okay, wenn da ja 5, ne das ist eine andere
Also 144 LEDs auf einen Meter ist so mit das dichteste was es gibt
Es gibt glaube ich noch mehr
Aber das ist nicht so üblich
144 ist eigentlich so das höchste
Das kann schon sein
Das ist schon möglich
Was hast du für ein Netzteil
Also du müsstest ja quasi nicht so sehr drauf gucken ob es ein 50 Watt Netzteil ist
Müsstest quasi drauf gucken, dass es ein 5 Volt Netzteil ist
Und dann je nachdem wie viel Ampere das Netzteil hat oder
Ja gut
Okay, 5 Volt, 3 Ampere sind schon mal nicht 50 Watt
Sondern nur 15
Also du müsstest dann beispielsweise ein 5 Volt 10 Ampere Netzteil kaufen
Gibt es auch
Aber ich auch hier
Diese Leike Dinger
Keine Ahnung ob das jetzt eine super krasse Marke ist oder sonst was
Davon habe ich auch ein paar da
Die funktionen wunderbar
Da musst du dir um das Netzteil keine Gedanken machen
Und dass der LED Strip kaputt geht
Würde ich also dass das irgendwie durchbrennt
Würde ich mir auch keine Gedanken machen
Du wirst es ja nicht wirklich auf 100% Helligkeit Weiß einstellen
Weil wenn du 100% Helligkeit und Weiß einstellst
Dann stellt sich mir die Frage warum nimmst du überhaupt ein RGB Strip
Jumperkabel Moment Moment Moment
Wie hast du sagen
Moment
Du kannst doch mit Jumperkabel kein 50 Watt Netzteil anschließen
Aber überhaupt kein Netzteil anschließen
Wie willst du mit einem Jumperkabel ein Netzteil dran
Hast du den Stecker abgemacht oder hast du dir selbst was dran gelötet
Oder
Also das geht auf keinen Fall
Du kannst keine 10 Ampere über so ein
Was hat denn so ein Jumperkabel für einen Durchschnitt
0,02 mm oder so
Nee das kannst du vergessen
Das geht nicht
0,05 das kannst du jetzt nicht machen
Also das kannst du vielleicht mal kurz machen und du wirst feststellen
Oh das wird ganz schön heiß
Also 10 Ampere über so ein Jumperkabel kannst du nicht machen
Wobei ich mich frage wie du das
Wo hast du es denn überhaupt dran angeschlossen
Weil normalerweise sind da hier keine Jumperkabel dran
Also was ich für RGB LEDs mache
Kann ich mal kurz zeigen
Ich hab so Stecker
Ich muss mal kurz
Kann man die auch als Armband verwenden
Naja wenn du einen Meter brauchst für ein Armband warum nicht
Das gibt es immer noch ja
Ähm sage ich gleich was zu
Ich würde kurz das Formel Ogen hier fertig besprechen
Und zwar bei 5,2 gehen die Jumperkabel
Also ganz ehrlich
Auch also so ein Jumperkabel
Ich meine es wird dir nicht in Flammen aufgehen
Aber ich würde auch nicht dauerhaft 15 Watt über so ein Jumperkabel machen
Es ist ja immer eine Frage ob es geht
Oder ob man es dauerhaft so betreiben soll
Du kannst ja beispielsweise auch aus einer normalen Steckdose
Bis zu 230 Volt 16 Ampere dir holen
Aber es wird ja auch explizit ja darauf hingewiesen
Ich weiß nicht ob das sogar nicht eventuell sogar in irgendwelchen Richtlinien steht
Dass man aus einer normalen Steckdose dauerhaft nicht mehr als 10 Ampere ziehen sollte
Also 230 Volt das ist natürlich mal eine ganz andere Hausnummer
Also das mit dem Jumperkabel würde ich auf jeden Fall nicht machen
Also Jumperkabel bei 50 Watt erscheint mir ein bisschen viel
Ein bisschen wenig des guten
Warum hast du Jumperkabel dran
Weil du wahrscheinlich noch einen Microcontroller anschließen willst
So ein bisschen mehr Informationen müsstest du noch schreiben
Weil ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher ob du mit Jumperkabel wirklich diese Mini Furz Kabel
meinst
Oder einfach nur ein bisschen kleinere Kabel die halt schön biegsam sind
Das ist da nicht so sehr das Problem
Ja ich weiß da kannst du die Pins rein ich kenne das
Ich kenne diese Stecker
Aber du musst ja vom Netzteil du musst ja vom Netzteil an diese
Hab ich jetzt zugemacht ich Kacknup
Du musst ja vom Netzteil an die Anschluss Stecker kommen
Also du musst ja hier dran
Wie machst du das
Hast du dann vom Netzteil den Stecker abgemacht
Oder hast du dort irgendwie was selbst dran gelötet
Ok also Raspberry Pi Pico
Bradboard 50 Watt
Ach du ziehst das Moment Moment
Hast du den LED Strip an den GPIO angeschlossen vom Raspberry Pi
Falls ja ist das eine ganz schlechte Idee
Aber du kannst froh sein das es noch geht
Das würde ich nicht machen
Auf gar keinen Fall den LED Strip an den GPIO aus vom Raspberry Pi anschließen
Ach nur den Datenpin ok
Dann ist gut dann ist alles gut
Also was du machen kannst ist folgendes
Also ich kann dir sagen wie ich das mache
Übrigens auch mit einem 5 Volt 10 Ampere Netzteil
Ich habe solche
Da kann man nämlich die auch schön in den Case einbauen
Ich habe solche Stecker
Ich weiß jetzt leider nicht genau wie die Dinger heißen
Das sind solche Hohlstecker
Aber ich weiß die heißen ja nicht so
Die heißen
Nee nee nee nicht dieses Ding
Hier sowas in der Richtung habe ich
Allerdings ohne
Ja sowas in der Richtung habe ich
So da kannst du nämlich das Netzteil reinstecken
Also du kannst hier ein schönes Case nehmen
Warum ist das so schlimm wenn man die an den GPIO anschließt
Weil die GPIOs bis maximal glaube ich 500 mA ausgelegt sind
5 Volt 500 mA also 5 mal 0,5 sind 2,5 Watt
Also 15 ist da schon arg fragwürdig
Sollte das über die GPIOs laufen
Ob das überhaupt geht und der Raspberry Pi nicht durchbrennt
Also die ESP GPIOs sind auf jeden Fall nur bis 500 mA
Und ich gehe mal davon aus die vom Raspberry Pi
Werden auch nicht für viel mehr sein
So also ich habe solche Dinger
Die kann man auch schön in den Gehäuse einbauen
Und da hinten dran kannst du dann
Entweder den
Also du brauchst ja sowas in der Richtung
Weil auf Spreadboard kommst du ja auch nicht einfach vom Netzteil
Also ich habe keine Ahnung wie das aktuell gemacht hast
Also wie kommst du von einem Netzteil
Ach hier ist ein Link vom Netzteil ok
Oh die Dinger sind Mist
Die habe ich auch
Kannst du vergessen
Falls das die gleichen sind die ich habe
Das auf gar keinen Fall 50 Watt da drüber machen
Das habe ich sogar mal im Stream gemacht
Das ist mega heiß geworden
Die Dinger sind richtig billig
Und haben wirklich mini mini mini Kabel drinnen
Also die haben ganz dünne Kabel hinter
Die Dinger taugen gar nichts
Ich weiß nicht was die hier unten schreiben
Für wie viel die denken
Dass das gedacht ist
Das würde ich nicht nehmen
Genau die gleichen habe ich auch
Und ich glaube sogar wir haben im Archiv
Wir haben im Archiv sogar noch den Stream drinne
Weiß ich aber links nicht nach was ich da suchen muss
Wir haben im Archiv glaube ich sogar den Stream drinne
Wo ich festgestellt habe
Das vielleicht
Wo ich festgestellt habe dass es etwas zu heiß wird
Ja ok keine Ahnung wo ich das gemacht habe
Vielleicht war das der Stream
Ja das ist der Stream
Also guck mal
Genau so ein Ding hast du
Leute wie ich den Stream auf den Punkt genau gesourcht habe
Wahnsinn hätte ich selbst nicht gedacht
Da ich den so schnell finde
Ich habe das hier genauso gemacht wie du
Nur dass es kein 144 pro Meter RGB Strip ist
Sondern glaube ich nur eine Stufe
Könnte sogar nur 30 sein
Also nicht viel
Hier habe ich es genauso gemacht wie du
Hier ist das Netzteil angeschlossen
Dann geht einmal per Kabel an die Anschlüsse vom LED Strip
Und hier geht es per Datenkabel an den Microcontroller
Also das kannst du knicken mit 50 Watt
So viel kann ich dir aus eigener Erfahrung sagen
Mit diesen Anschlüssen kannst du es knicken
Also was du machen solltest
Was auch gut funktioniert ist
So was hier in der Richtung
Es gibt die Dinge auch komplett ohne Kabel
So was hier in der Richtung ist sinnvolle Investition
Kostet ja nicht viel
Und da kannst du das Netzteil reinstecken
Dann hast du ordentliche Kabel
Wie gesagt es gibt die gleichen Stecker auch ohne Kabel
Da musst du es selbst ran löten
Ist je nachdem was du machen willst sogar noch praktischer
Weil da kannst du theoretisch direkt die LED Strips hier ran löten
Wenn du das willst
Und du kriegst diese Anschlüsse auch schön in einen Case rein
Dass es dann zu ist
Nimmst du irgendein billiges Plastikkase für 2,50
Machst die rein und dann hast du auch ein geschlossenes Case
Wo du schön den Netzteil anschließen kannst
Also die Dinger sind auf jeden Fall deutlich besser dafür
Hier hast du auch dickere Kabel dran
Weiß gar nicht für wie viel das hier ausgelegt ist
Musst du gucken ich find's jetzt grad nicht
Ah hier 18AWG
Leute 5-Hat-Hi-IQ Leute
18AWG
Wie viel geht das so bei 5 Volt
So viel Ahnung hab ich von Elektrotechnik auch nicht
Als dass ich das wüsste
Textsuche ist richtig nice
Dann schließt du da dran deinen LED Strip an
Und auch die Versorgungspins für deinen Microcontroller
Und dann noch ein Datapin an den Strip und Gutes
Hier die Textsuche mit Whisper
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher mit was er das gemacht hat
Die Textsuche
Aber die hat auf jeden Fall für die initiale Indexierung eine Woche gebraucht
Mit einer Dual-RTX 3090
Nicht 350
Also das war schon ein bisschen fetter die Kiste
Also so würd ichs machen
So hab ichs bei mir auch gemacht
Der Anschluss ist viel besser als das was du hast
Also diese grünen Adapter kannst du vergessen
Die hab ich auch
Das fackelt dir halb ab
Das hatte ich ja auch bei mir im Stream probiert
Das wird richtig heiß nach ein paar Minuten schon
Würde ich auf gar keinen Fall machen
Nehm sowas hier in der Richtung
Schließ die RGB Strips an
Dann Datapin und so und alles ist gut
Dann kannst du da auch einen 50 Watt Netzteil dran hauen
Das ist kein Ding
5 Volt, 10 Ampere Netzteil und Gibi
Wie gesagt der zieht das eh nicht
Du musst doch mal gucken ob der das überhaupt braucht
Wirklich brauchen tun die Dinger das nur wenn du sie hell machst auf weiß
15 Watt reicht wahrscheinlich für einen Meter sogar aus
Wenn du die auf ne schöne Farbe einstellst
Eventuell sogar noch ein paar Effekte anmachst
Die Effekte sorgen in der Regel dafür
Dass es weniger Leistung zieht
Weil die Helligkeit schwankt
Google empfiehlt noch mindestens einen 100
Was ist das?
Mikrofarad oder sowas?
High IQ Chat?
Kondensator für verwenden
Warum kann ich da jeden verwenden?
Warum empfehlen die einen Kondensator?
An welcher Stelle empfehlen die überhaupt einen Kondensator?
Das ist wahrscheinlich irgendwas für Spannungsspitzen oder so
Ich hab keinen Plan
Dafür hab ich nicht genug Plan von Spannungsspitzen sag ich doch
Das würde ich jetzt drauf tippen
Ehrlich ich hab an keinem einzigen RGB Strip oder Matrix ein Kondensator davor
Kann sein das es irgendwann mal kaputt geht
Beim Einschalten aber bis jetzt war das noch nicht der Fall
Wo siehts aus?
Ok so was wollte ich?
Ich wollte noch auf was anderes hier eingehen
Chat ich hab gesagt ich sag gleich was drauf und hab da nichts zugesagt
Was steht heute an?
Chatting steht heute an
Hier vielleicht eine dumme Frage
Was passiert eigentlich wenn der Verantwortliche von solchen Ereignissen nicht mehr dort arbeitet?
Nix?
Was soll passieren?
Theoretisch könntest du wenn es ein Externer ist
Könntest du den irgendwie auf Schadensersatz verklagen oder so
Aber ich bin mir nicht sicher ob sowas überhaupt schon mal von Erfolg gekrönt war in diesem
Umfang
Da müsstest du dir dem nachweisen dass der irgendwie grob fahrlässig was gemacht hat
Außerdem wird er sagen er hat das eben auf Auftrag gemacht und der Auftrag war eben genauso
gestellt und da wirst du nichts machen können
Da passiert einfach gar nichts
Wenn die Verantwortlichen nicht mehr da sind passiert gar nichts
Es wird vielleicht ein bisschen gelästert dass die eh kacke waren und keinen Plan hatten
oder was noch immer aber da passiert nichts
Hast du damals auch to... ja hab ich tatsächlich aber nie sonderlich viel
Also ich kenn die allerersten Games
Aber ich hab ich glaube ich hab ich so noch nicht mal durchgespielt
Bisschen leiser mann
Ok
Das stimmt
Ich glaube aber das ist ihm schon klar gewesen so wie er gefragt hat
Und deswegen das ist ja auch der Grund warum ich gesagt hab mess erst mal nach was denn
überhaupt dein LED RGB Strip aktuell so verbraucht
Weil vielleicht brauchst du das 50 Watt Netzteil gar nicht
Aber ich glaube das ist ihm schon klar
Was man vielleicht bei Netzteilen noch dazu sagen sollte
Man kann natürlich auch ein 1000 Watt Netzteil verwenden
Für nen Computer zum Beispiel der nur Eidl läuft und 20 Watt verbraucht
Das Ding ist nur in der Regel
Ich kenn mich nicht gut genug dafür aus das ich jetzt sagen könnte ist immer so
Aber in der Regel ist es auch ein bisschen blöd was den Stromverbrauch angeht
Weil die Netzteile umso weniger sie ausgelastet sind oftmals umso schlechteren Wirkungsgrad
haben
Das sieht man auch beispielsweise bei Netzwerktests wo es um diese Platinum Titanium Bronze Gold
Zertifizierung geht
Die sind auch oftmals erst ab einer gewissen Auslastung so gut
Deswegen macht es gar keinen Sinn überdimensionierte Netzteile zu verwenden
Es sei denn man hat irgendwas dranhängen was halt in Spitzenzeiten dann auch mal so viel
ziehen kann
Dann natürlich schon
Aber wenn man irgendwie so kleinen Kram hängen hat muss das nicht an einem 1000 Watt Netzteil
hängen oder so
In dem Fall hier macht es jetzt nicht viel Unterschied
Aber wie gesagt ich würde es mal messen ich könnte mir vorstellen wahrscheinlich braucht
sein LED Strip gar nicht so viel
Ach ja und wenn du WLED Logan wenn du WLED benutzt dann musst du in WLED noch den Schalter
raus machen dass der die Helligkeit limitiert
WLED versucht ja intern die Helligkeit zu limitieren dass du wahrscheinlich deinen Netzteil
nicht überlastest oder so was
Oder dass es zu heiß wird das kannst du knicken
Das würde ich rausnehmen oder auf einen viel zu hohen Wert stellen
Weil die Berechnung hat bei mir nie wirklich gut hingehauen
Heute spielt Frankfurt oh das geht mir so was vor dem Arsch vorbei
Puzzle Meister danke für den Sub
Ja wenn du paar Klemmen hast ist tatsächlich ganz gut
Das ist zum testen auf jeden Fall sinnvoll
Da gibt es kann ich tatsächlich auch nur empfehlen
Für alle die ein bisschen Elektrogramm basteln und Leute ich rede absichtlich bei Elektrogramm
nur von so Microcontroller Geschichten und kleinen Elektronikprojekten
Ich rede nie davon dass ihr irgendwas an der Steckdose machen sollt
Das kannst du zwar auch mit den Klemmen machen aber das wollt ihr nicht machen
Es sei denn ihr wollt euch umbringen wenn ihr keine Ahnung habt
Ja gut dann kann ich dann auch nichts mehr für
So was hier kann ich wirklich jedem empfehlen der ein bisschen Elektro-Bastel-Gramm macht
So eine Box hier
Ich mach jetzt mal exemplarisch die auf gibt es ja noch mehrere
So ein Vago-Klemmen Sortiment
Kann ich euch wirklich nur wärmstens empfehlen
Ist für alles praktisch was ihr Elektronik Sachen machen wollt
Zum Beispiel
Du hast keinen mit weißer LED
Macht ja nix
Du kannst den trotzdem auf weiß stellen dann brauch er am meisten Strom
Aber wenn ihr Elektro-Gramm bastelt ist das Ding sehr praktisch
Das ist total simpel in der Anwendung man sieht es ja hier das sind Klemmen
Dann macht ihr hier hoch rauf hier Klipps auf Klipps auf
Kabel rein stecken Klipps zu und das hält Bomben fest
Also bevor die Klemme kaputt geht reißt ihr eher das Kabel ab
Das Kabel raus und die Rätste bleiben drinnen hängen
Also die Dinger sind super
Vor allem ihr habt einmal doppelte Dinger zum Kabel einfach nur verbinden
Oder eben auch um da mehrere Sachen anzuschließen
Also die sind wirklich nice die Dinger
Und so ein Sortiment die kann man auch wieder verwenden
Die kann man auch wieder verwenden
Also wenn ihr die mal nur kurz braucht
Wahrscheinlich haben die offiziell irgendwas drauf stehen
Maximal 50 mal auf und zu machbar oder was auch immer
Wahrscheinlich leiern die auch aus mit der Zeit oder kriegen Bollen innen drinnen
Keine Ahnung
Aber ich hab schon einige Klemmen jetzt öfters verwendet das funktioniert wunderbar
Und das gute an den Klemmen ist
Also man kriegt sie einfach wieder ab
Besser als irgendwelche Durchsteckverbinder wo man es nicht gescheit wieder rauskriegt
Das coole ist dass die zugelassen sind
Für die aller aller
Also was heißt zugelassen oder
Dass man die benutzen kann
Für die aller aller meisten Kabelquerschnitts Dinger die man so benutzt
Also die gehen
Die gehen von ganz kleinen Sachen
Oh das ist übrigens auch nice
Die gehen von ganz kleinen Kabel
Bis dickere Kabel
Für starre Kabel
Für litzen Kabel
Für alles mögliche
Also das ist praktisch sowas zu haben
Und falls ihr was zum Abisolieren braucht
Ist das Ding auch nicht schlecht
Wo wir gerade dabei sind
Der Abisolierchamp
Den hab ich auch
Der ist sehr praktisch
Wenn man kleine Leitungen abisolieren will
Für fette Sachen ist das nix
Also wenn ihr Kabel abisolieren wollt die so dick sind wie euer kleiner Finger
Dann ist das nix
Aber für die meisten die einem so unterkommen ist das perfekt das Teil
Hätten wir das auch geklärt
Das hat nur der Serious Max gemacht
Also ich mag alle meine Modges aber in dem Fall muss man tatsächlich sagen
Der Lob dafür gebührt nur dem Serious Max
Glaubt ihr der einzige der an dem Frontend rumgebastelt hat
Und auch die AI Suche gemacht hat
Die AI Transcribe Geschichte gemacht hat
Welches Tool für VMs kannst du empfehlen?
Fände Typ 1 eigentlich ganz interessant
Würde mich langsam aber sicher gerne weiterhin...
Okay ich glaube du spielst an auf diese Geschichte mit Type 1 Hypervisor und sowas
Das ist aber in dem Fall total egal
Weil du dich danach richten solltest was dein Anwendungszweck ist
Und in der Regel willst du ja deinen Rechner für was verwenden
Und gleichzeitig VMs laufen haben
Und wenn das Windows ist dann bleibt dir nicht viel anderes übrig
Wie zum Beispiel sowas wie Vmware Workstation, Virtualbox oder Vmware Player oder sowas zu
verwenden
Ja man kann theoretisch Hyper-V verwenden
Aber ich weiß nicht ob irgendjemand ernsthaft auf Desktop Virtualisierung mit Hyper-V macht
Und damit zufrieden ist
Chat, verwendet jemand von euch Hyper-V auf dem Desktop um beispielsweise Linux VMs mit
grafischem UI zu virtualisieren?
Also wir kämen nicht auf die Idee ehrlich gesagt
Ich würd's nicht machen
Linux Desktop lecken wie Sau, das wundert mich nicht
Ja WSL benutzt Hyper-V, das ist richtig
Doch doch
Bei WSL läuft ja die grafische Oberfläche nicht über diese Hyper-V Ausgabe
Sondern die haben ja mit WSLG ihren eigenen Krempel
Also im Prinzip ist ja dann die grafische Sache nicht in Hyper-V drinnen
Google empfiehlt noch mindestens
Achso Moment da war mal grad
This Game Sucks sag ich gleich was zu, das geht besser als man denkt
Daniel Lull danke für den Sub
44 Monate Alter
Massive
Dazu kann ich nur sagen
Easy
Ist WSLG nicht fancy verpacktes RDP?
Ich hab keine Ahnung wenn ich ehrlich bin
Weiß nicht
Es muss ja auf jeden Fall irgendeine X-Implementierung auf der einen Seite sein
Und wie dann die Daten rübergeschickt werden zu Windows
Also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass es RDP ist
Das wäre mir
Also der Umweg über RDP wäre mir etwas ernsthaft
Das ist RDP?
Das stelle ich mir viel zu umständlich vor
Ich mein mich wundert es auf der einen Seite nicht
Weil Microsoft bei RDP ja Extensions hat seit Jahren
Dass man beispielsweise auch bei Windows Terminal Servern teilweise Grafikkartenfunktionen
mit benutzen kann
Die im Server drinnen sind
Das nennt sich dann irgendwie RDP mit
Ich hab vergessen wie es heißt
Also wundert mich auf der Seite nicht
Aber was mich wundert ist
Warum er in dem Fall überhaupt sowas wie RDP machen muss
Wir können uns gleich mal angucken
Weil normalerweise musst du einen X-Server
Du brauchst einen X-Server
Ja genau hier
Support Wayland X
Du brauchst so eine Art X-Server
Und der muss das dann quasi translaten zu irgendwas was du in der Windows anzeigen kannst
Also ich hätte jetzt vermutet dass die auf RDP und sowas scheißen
Sondern einfach den so quasi virtuellen Framebuffer
Abgreifen von ihrem X-Server und dann rendern über irgendwas in Windows
Hätte gar nicht gedacht dass da wirklich RDP im Spiel ist
Und da ist ein Graf wie es funktioniert
Ach hier tatsächlich
Ganz gern RDP
Ernsthaft das ist RDP?
Wirklich?
Aber das erscheint mir total umständlich
Auf der lokalen Kiste grafische Sachen per RDP zu machen
Wenn man einfach irgendwie den Buffer rüber kopieren könnte
Und dann in DirectX oder in Windows AP ins Fenster rendern
Warum ist da RDP dazwischen?
Also ich meine ja es ist nur VM
Da greift man mal nicht so einfach den Buffer ab
Aber das ist ja kein Ding Microsoft programmiert den Kram ja
Unter Linux geht das ja übrigens auch
Unter Linux gibt es ja auch so Sachen wie Looking Glass und solche Geschichten
Die machen das ja
Die greifen quasi das Bild direkt aus dem Grafikspeicher der VM ab
Schicken es ans Hausbetriebssystem und rendern es da
Und es ist halt viel schneller als irgendwelcher RDP Kram
Es hat glaube ich maximal 1-2 Frames Verzögerung
Ja ok
Was auch immer ist mir neu wusste ich nicht dass Windows das benutzt
Aber wer weiß
Wer weiß was sich Microsofts Python Leute dabei gedacht haben
Ja aber auch mal auf diese Frage zurück zu kommen
Ich empfehle dir wenn du einen Windows Desktop hast
Forever Workstation
Warum empfehle ich dir das?
Naja ich verwende das auch
Da hier guck VM
Fullscreen
Hups
Habe ich jetzt auf Update geklickt oder auf
So
Ich verwende auch Forever Workstation
Und mit Forever Workstation kannst du schöne Sachen machen
Das größte kannst du mit Virtual Box und so auch machen keine Frage
Aber Virtual Box ist was UI und 3D 2D Acceleration angeht nicht so gut
Damit kannst du dann coole Sachen machen wie zum Beispiel
Du kannst relativ schnell zwischen Windows und Linux umschalten
Guck da Windows da Linux da leere Desktop Windows
Linux Windows Windows Linux Windows Windows Linux
Und ich finde diesen Workflow recht angenehm
Deswegen habe ich das so mit VM-Ware auf dem zweiten Bildschirm
Oder äh auf dem zweiten Desktop
Ja mit Linux als Host geht das genauso
Wobei ich halt der Meinung bin das
Also das Switchen
Wobei ich halt der Meinung bin es ist viel einfacher
Linux unter Windows zu virtualisieren als Windows unter Linux
Was wäre ein gutes Microcontroller Projekt zum Einstieg
Ganz ehrlich
Wenn du Bock auf RGB Strips hast ist das ein super Projekt zum Einstieg
Weil man extrem viele coole Sachen damit machen kann
Also wenn du auf sowas stehst
Und WLED in der Anwendung total easy ist
Da kannst du aber schon mal gucken wie flasht man so einen Microcontroller
Auf was muss ich beim Anschließen achten
Zum Beispiel wo wir es eben davon hatten
Gibt ja Leute die kommen auf die Idee zum Beispiel ihren RGB Strip
An den GPIOs des Microcontrollers anzuschließen
Und denken sich dann oh das funktioniert das ist eine gute Idee
Aber wie gesagt eigentlich ist es eine ziemliche scheiß Idee
Weil du relativ schnell deinen Microcontroller kaputt machst
Deinen LED Strip wirst du nicht kaputt machen
Aber deinen Microcontroller machst du kaputt
Weil die GPIO Pins
Wenn du überhaupt einen 5 Volt Output hast
Ich meine übrigens nicht die GPIOs sind falsch
Die 5 Volt Output Pins
Die sind aber meistens nur gedacht für maximal 250 oder 500 mA
Und so einen RGB Strip kommst du mit 2,5 Watt nicht weit bei einem RGB Strip
Inklusive dem Microcontroller
Was man braucht
Wasser essen Dankeschön für den Zapp
Und die Leute stellen dann fest
Ups jetzt ist mein Microcontroller abgeraucht
Das sind so Sachen die lernt man dann schon mal ganz gut
RGB ist glaube ich gar nicht so blöd
Also wenn man Bock auf sowas hat
Dann bin ich RGB zum Einstieg zum Basteln gar nicht verkehrt
Es gibt ja coole Sachen die man machen kann
Man muss nicht einfach sinnlos RGB Strips
Man kann sich so eine eigene kleine Lampe bauen
Kann man sich auch seinen 3D Drucker gleich einspannen für wenn man sowas hat
Ansonsten es gibt ja Gott und die Welt an Microcontroller Projekte
Du kannst deine Klingel im Haus smart machen
Indem du guckst ob es klingelt und dann kannst du Notification schicken
Du kannst irgendwie deine Waage smart machen
Dass es überträgt wie schwer du bist
Alles mögliches es gibt tausende Möglichkeiten was du machen kannst
Aber ich finde wenn man Bock auf LED Beleuchtung auf RGB Beleuchtung hat
Da ein bisschen zu basteln ist zum Einstieg eigentlich ganz nice
Ne, ah Logan bist noch da ich lese jetzt erst
Ne das liegt woanders dran ne ne ne ne
Das liegt woanders dran
Das ist ein anderes das liegt nicht am letzt Teil per se
Das liegt am Widerstand
Das LED Strips
Das sind 5 Volt LED Strips
Also das muss ich jetzt vielleicht auch nochmal sagen
Also er sagt hier ich habe zwei von diesen Strips verbunden
Und der erste Strip
Ne der zweite Strip ist dunkler
Also einer von beiden Strips ist dunkler als den
Das liegt am Widerstand von dem Strip
Das sind ja 5 Volt LED Strips
Das heißt am Ende vom ersten Strip sind das dann keine 5 Volt mehr
Sondern keine Ahnung 3,8 oder so was da noch übrig ist
Die Dinger werden immer dunkler umso länger sie sind
Beziehungsweise umso mehr LEDs sie durch müssen
Allein schon das Kabel hat ja einen Widerstand
Das liegt daran das es zu lang wird
Um das zu beheben gibt es zwei Varianten
Entweder man schließt vorne und hinten das Netzteil an
Das ist die einfachste Variante
Also du stöpselst den Stecker am Anfang in den Mikrocontroller und ins Netzteil
Und den Stecker hinten ins Netzteil
Oder machst halt noch zwei kleine Kabel hinten zu dem Stecker wenn es so nicht geht
Aber du musst es vorne und hinten einstecken
Dann sind beide LED Strips höchstwahrscheinlich hell genug
Wenn nicht
Wenn es so lang wird dass es nicht reicht
Dann musst du dazwischen immer wieder injecten
Was du aber bei zwei LED Strips höchstwahrscheinlich nicht brauchst
Wenn du jetzt allerdings deine ganze Hauswand mit LED Strips voll hast
Dann musst du wahrscheinlich nach 2,3 oder nach jedem Strip am besten nochmal 5 Volt
Injecten
Dass es alles schon gleichmäßig hell ist
Wobei ich das Haus auch nicht mit 5 Volt LED Strips machen würde allein schon aus diesem
Grund
Da ist wahrscheinlich ein 12 Volt LED Strip deutlich angenehmer
Oder vielleicht sogar ein 24 Volt LED Strip
Weil da hast du nicht so Probleme mit dem Voltage Stop durch den Widerstand der Leitung
Das ist dann weniger ein Problem
Aber 5 Volt LED Strips sind natürlich unglaublich praktisch für Anwendungen im Haus
Wo man jetzt keine Meterlange LED Strips legt
Weil man kann halt das gleiche Netzteil ohne Sperenz verwenden für den Controller und
die LED Strips
Nice Witz chat
Ok kann sein ich benutze das Ding für alles funktioniert wunderbar
Richtig er hat es schon gesagt
Ja
In der VM dann ein neuronales Netz trainieren ist in VirtualBox wohl dann auch super langsam
oder als Beispiel
Nee
Also gehen wir jetzt mal von es ist egal ob VirtualBox
Oder
VmWorkstation
Ist es eigentlich egal
Wir nehmen jetzt mal als Beispiel VmWorkstation
Leute
Fällt jemand einen guten Bench doch Cinebench gibt es gibt es gibt Cinebench auch für für
Linux
Nee
Fällt jemand ein Benchmark ein
Den es für Linux und für Windows gibt Prime95
Ah Prime95 ist ein doofer Benchmark
Gibt es da irgendwas gutes
Geekbench
Ich will irgendwas was einen CPU Core richtig richtig heftig nicht machen kann Geekbench
Ich zeige dir das jetzt mal
Oh ok bevor ich das mache erst mal fragen
This Game Sucks bist du noch da
Weil ich muss das jetzt nicht zeigen
Wenn er schon weg ist weg ist weg ist
Rezino Dankeschön Dankeschön für den Sub
Also ich sag erst mal was dazu ich sag erst mal was dazu
Und dann zeige ich dir dass es so ist
Also wenn du vom Trainieren redest mit Grafikkarten mit GPUs dann ist das nicht anwendbar was
ich jetzt gleich sage
Weil wenn du mit GPUs trainieren willst braucht deine Vm natürlich Zugriff auf die GPU direkt
auf die GPU
Und dementsprechend funktioniert das nur mit GPU passthrough und das kannst du unter Windows
mit VmWorkstation und sowas nicht machen
Ich bin mir nicht sicher ob Hyper-V unter Windows GPU passthrough kann
Auf Windows Server kann es das
Aber auf Windows 11 weiß ich nicht ob es das kann
Vielleicht wahrscheinlich kann man es irgendwie hinwurschteln
Will man aber eher nicht
So wenn du das über die CPU machst und das ist das was ich dir jetzt gleich zeige
Wenn du das über die CPU machst wirst du feststellen die Performance einer modernen
CPU ist in der Vm und auf deinem Host nahezu nicht voneinander zu unterscheiden
Was nehmen wir Geekbench habe ich noch nie verwendet Leute Geekbench wie sieht das aus
Bei?
Ja Moment ich brauche irgendwas
Kann man das kostenlos verwenden?
Und nur für die CPU please ja
Ok Geekbench, dann lernen wir heute noch was
Ich hab Geekbench noch nie verwendet
Aber jetzt Geekbench
Aber WSL ist auch Hyper-V
Ok WSL 2 das erste WSL nicht
Das erste WSL ist quasi sowas wie Rewind
So ein bisschen
Ok Geek
Ich denke das hat eine UI hat das kein UI?
Was für ein Linux Arch Linux selbstverständlich
Cringe
Wie kannst du von was anderem ausgehen
By the way
Ok Gentoo wäre vielleicht noch erlaubt gewesen
Aber wie kannst du von was anderem ausgehen als dem einzig wahren Arch Linux Mensch
Wie hast du denn Terminal transparent hinbekommen ich bekomme es einfach nicht hin
Das zeige ich dir gleich wenn der Geekbench durch ist
Hör ich das überhaupt richtig aus Leute?
Kann man nicht einfach nur den Single Core Test machen?
Oder muss man jetzt alles durchlaufen lassen?
Nee, Xetos ist stimmt prinzipiell aber muss ein bisschen mehr machen
Ok wir lassen es mal kurz laufen
Geekbench run only one CPU
Ja genau
Das Ding nicht irgendwelche ich kann schon mal download Geekbench
Download Windows
Ist das ein Single File executable oder ist das irgendein Excel irgendein Setup
Multi Core
Nee nee
Ok das sackt das muss ich mal abbrechen help
cpu run a CPU Benchmark
cpu help
Alter das geht mir ja schon wieder auf den Sack dass man hier nichts angeben kann
Geekbench run only Single CPU
Soll ich das aufmachen?
Naja ich trau mich mal
Ach das gibt es nicht
Man kann nicht nur Single Core
Ok dann gucken wir uns halt nur die Single Core Performance gleich an
Geekbench läuft meines Wissens alles durch und lädt das ganze dann auf die
Was?
Ich will meine Sachen nicht veröffentlichen ich will einfach nur das anzeigen man
Gibt es eine Playlist ja das ist
Relaxing Mario Music oder sowas hier
Relaxing and Calming Music vom Mario Series
Setup kann man den Scheiß nicht einfach so ausführen?
Standalone Geekbench
Ah Pro, Pro natürlich
Das geht nur mit Pro
Das ist eine gute Idee
7-Zip Benchmark das ist eine sehr gute Idee
Das ist gut
Wie funktioniert das?
Was ist der 7-Zip Benchmark 7-Zip minus B
Habe ich überhaupt 7-Zip drauf?
Warum muss man Benchmark ich hab keine Ahnung das ist total bescheuert
Hier habe ich 7-Zip drauf?
Ne
Das ist eine gute Idee wir machen das
Ok warum habe ich denn 7-Zip?
Habe ich 7-Zip?
Ne Entschuldigung
Ernsthaft habe ich das noch nicht auf dem neuen Rechner drauf?
Brauche ich eh
7-Zip
Jo
Was ist der?
Ah hier das da
Ja ich habe es aber nicht installiert glaube ich muss erst mal installieren
Install jawoll
Close
Ok das ging schnell
7-Zip
So und jetzt kann ich das hier ausführen
Ne
Ok wir sind unter Windows da sind die Sachen nicht so einfach
Einfach mal installieren und dann funktioniert das
Wie kann man das, kann man CLI nicht unter Windows ausführen geht das nicht?
Wo liegt denn der Mist jetzt überhaupt?
Ich kann doch mal den
Windows ich hasse dieses System dieses System ist so ultra Bullshit man
Warum kann ich nicht die File Location einfach andrücken wo das ist?
Ah ok geht auch so
Alter es regt mich so auf
Hier 7-Zip da ist es doch
Was muss ich drücken?
Shift?
Seriously?
Warum?
Was ist das für ein Schwachsinn?
So?
Was?
So wie führe ich das jetzt aus?
Ok 7-Zip nein nein Exe
Ok ist Geekbench jetzt durch?
Uploaded successfully
Ok nice sehr schön
Mal gucken wir uns mal ein Geekbench Geekbench Score an
2404 ok interessiert mich aber eh nicht
Aber nice
Poggers Poggers Geekbench
Ok 7-Zip
B
Ja bei mir anscheinend geht das anscheinend nicht
Moment ich mache gerade alle CPU Cores
Help
What?
B
Und dann wo gebe ich die CPU Kern Anzahl ein?
Ok geil perfekt sehr gut
CPU Cores
Benchmark Command
Was?
Es kann doch nicht so schwer sein
Irgendeine Hilfe Datei zu schreiben
Oder Commando Zeilen Option zu machen Minus Minus Cores oder sowas
Was?
MMT1?
Ach Number of Threats MMT
Alles klar
Da weißt du ja war Bescheid
Wir könnten jetzt Chat GPT fragen
Ok also Minus Minus Minus MMT
Ach nee Moment Minus nicht Minus Minus
Ok so 1 CPU Core Benchmark
Was auch immer wir merken uns einfach mal diese Werte jetzt
Und machen das jetzt mal auf dem Host MMT1
Äh stimmt was nicht
Der Unterschied ist viel zu groß
Ach nee jetzt gehts runter ok alles klar
Ne das stimmt nicht der Unterschied ist viel zu groß dafür
Ich hab kein Schimmer was das Ding macht
Er ist ja auch der Meinung es ist bloß
Hier ist er der Meinung es ist 100% Usage
Ist ja auch das macht nix CPU Virtualisierung macht im Endeffekt kein Unterschied großartig
Ähm aber das hier stimmt ja auch schon mal irgendwie nett
Quatsch das ist top aktuelle 7-Zip Version bam
Ja 2017
Warum ist denn das so alt?
Ich krieg noch die Krise mann
Warum ist das so ein riesen Akt?
Hier das da kann ich jetzt sehen ok
Warum ist das so ein riesen Akt einfach so ne fucking Single Core Benchmark durchzuführen?
Ok
P
Ich verstehs dann
Und warum ist das hat jemand irgendeinen Plan warum das so alt ist?
Ok wir kompilieren erst mal selbst auf gehts jawoll
Schadet ja nix
Kleines Programm mit 1000 Zeilen
Ich dachte mir eigentlich ist es einfacher wir hätten irgendwie mal ein Single Core Benchmark
aber gut naja
Ok wir müssen jetzt erst mal 7-Zip leider kompilieren
Also der Unterschied ist auf jeden Fall viel zu groß
7000 irgendwas zu 5600 ok wisst ihr was tatsächlich sein kann
dass es bei mir nicht richtig aussagekräftig ist
weil
ich hab ja in 13900k
und je nachdem ob das auf nem efficiency Core oder auf nem performance Core landet
da bin ich mir nicht sicher wie VMWare das handelt
ich müsste wahrscheinlich irgendwie in VMWare einstellen oder das an den Core pinnen das
ist oder irgendwie an die Cores pinnen oder was auch immer
das kann natürlich sein dass es auf meiner CPU nicht wirklich aussagekräftig ist
ok machen wir mal nen Benchmark
ah ok schon schon besser schon besser naja wobei nicht wirklich
ok also auf die Gefahr hin dass das nicht wirklich aussagekräftig ist
aber du siehst der Unterschied ist jetzt auch nicht wirklich gravierend
also allein schon jetzt und wahrscheinlich gibt es Probleme mit dem Scheduler
und ich laufe manchmal auf nem efficiency Core anstatt auf nem performance Core was
immer
also siehst jetzt schon der Unterschied ist rein mit diesem wirklich nicht
sonderlich aussagekräftigen Benchmark nicht so groß
Durchschnitt 7317 zu 6076 ja das ist ein Unterschied
aber der ist in der Praxis oder wenn man es ordentlich testen würde ist er noch geringer
also der Performance Unterschied rein CPU Performance ist zwischen Host und VM nicht
groß
der ist ich würde sogar so weit gehen der ist meistens sogar noch im Bereich der Messungenauigkeit
wenn man es gescheit macht
also da musst du dir keine Gedanken machen wenn ordentlich wenn ordentlich fetten
und jetzt noch ne Virtual Box testen also wenn ne
was wir mal ausprobieren können ist mit zwei mit zwei Kern vielleicht vielleicht ist das
besser
wie virtualisiert vmw werden die Features eins zu eins durchgereicht
also wie es vmw genau macht weiß wahrscheinlich nur vmw
es wird es wird wahrscheinlich
ah guck mal hier
jetzt hat man auch mehr als doppelt so viel es ist tatsächlich
meine CPU ist da ein bisschen merkwürdig mit diesen zwei verschiedenen Core Arten
wahrscheinlich macht vmw irgendwelche Magic Low Level Umschreibgeschichten und benutzt
die Virtualisierungsfunktion in der CPU
allein schon weil die alle die Virtualisierungsfunktion in der CPU benutzen kann das nicht großartig
Performance Unterschied sein
ich müsste jetzt mal gucken wie man in vmw ausschaltet oder wie man in vmw einstellt
das ist efficiency cores nicht verwendet
ok guck jetzt sind wir ok total
es wird immer es wird immer geringer der Unterschied siehste
machen wir mal vier da hab ich jetzt wahrscheinlich eher glück
im Windows oder im Hintergrund dass ich auf den auf den richtigen
Cores lande ja meine CPU ist jetzt blöd um das zu zeigen
das stimmt irgendwie schon
genau das denke ich nämlich auch lesium dass das sowas in der richtung sein wird
ja keine ahnung aber was man schon dran sieht in diesem wirklich nicht sonderlich scientific
high IQ test
es ist kein großer unterschied zwischen vm und haus performance
ich meine ich kann mal sechs kerne oder acht wieviel habe ich hier drinnen acht
ok komm wir geben wir geben immer volle pulle
acht frets
wieso vor allem bei workstation weil ich vor allem bei workstation lieber benutze als
virtualbox das liegt einmal am ui und das liegt daran
dass gp das 3d und 2d acceleration besser ist
gleich mit das schmiert das streamer oder der stream schmiert nicht ab
das stream steht schon aus dem grund nicht ab weil ich 24 kerne oder so hab
keine ahnung ich glaube meine cpu ist nicht gut um das zu demonstrieren
wahrscheinlich müsste ich gucken dass das ich müsste wahrscheinlich vor allem beibringen
dass es nur performance course benutzt dass es richtig klappt
also das stream schmiert nicht ab weil ich hab genug cpu kerne
so und das hier man sieht es ja hier ganz gut es sind 32 logische kerne 24 course und
von diesen 24 course sind 16 quasi stromsparende kerne
nee warte mal 12 16 oder 16 und 8 ich weiß es gar nicht genau ich glaube 16 ich glaube
ich glaube 16 und 8 genau also 8 8 performance course und 16 efficiency course und wenn ich
jetzt halt in der vm auf den auf den efficiency course lande die sind lang die sind ungefähr
glaube ich 30 prozent langsamer oder so als die performance course deswegen kommt es nicht hin
weiß ich ich bin mir gar nicht sicher ob man das in vm irgendwie einstellen kann
kein plan du kannst im vmx file einstellen welche course er benutzt ach scheiß drauf
zumindest der test ist ist schon mal richtig wie soll man denn wie nennt man das
wenn der test nicht aussagekräftig also der test ist schon mal nicht aussagekräftig wirklich
gewesen aber man hat auch schon an diesem nicht wirklich guten test gesehen dass die
unterschiede zwischen der performance host und vm nicht groß sind
du kannst den winners task manager nee so einfach ist es in dem fall glaube ich nicht
weil es ja nicht weil es ja das hier weil es ja nicht das hier ist oder ist es ist es
dass sie ja vor immer service ist es wahrscheinlich der was brauchen jetzt tp hier vor immer
workstation formix das könnte man das könnte man wahrscheinlich sagen ja und und wie wie
pinned man da jetzt kerne das ist jetzt interessant das muss ich jetzt tatsächlich mal kurz
ausprobieren wie pinned man da jetzt kerne wie geht das properties nee hat jemand eine
ahnung wie das geht oder muss man das hier drüber irgendwie
oder muss man das hier drüber machen was go to detail
und jetzt und jetzt set affinity ne och man scheint ja high IQ shit zu sein wir uns unter
winnows zu machen ok wie startet man den ok ok das muss ich jetzt mal winnows winnows
logik alles klar cmd ok run as administrator alles klar und jetzt task wie startet man
den task manager übers terminal task mgr oder so hey wahnsinn ok so user ok set affinity
und welche und woher weiß ich jetzt welche davon performance course sind sind sind die
nuller ok ich hoffe mal die ersten 24 warum vier uns warum warum 24 acht kerne mit hyper
threading 16 also die dann sind die ersten acht sind auf jeden fall warum ist das jetzt
weggegangen ok probieren wir noch mal ob das irgendeine aus irgendeine auswirkung hat
ja wobei nee oder 0 bis 7 nicht 0 bis 8 ihr habt rechts 0 bis 7 chat chat ist wieder
way too schlau ja ein bisschen besser ok kein kein plan
das macht dann eben schon kein unterschied machen wir mal zwei stopper zwei ist noch
am ersten zu sehen eigentlich wollte ich jetzt nicht großartige benchmark action machen aber
gut ok 20 verses und die was war das c doppelpunkt program files 7 zippe da nicht acht zwei
also ein großer unterschied ist es jetzt aber auch schon mit dem test nicht 20 ungefähr
versus 22 muss ich mir vielleicht mal überlegen wie man das wie man das noch besser testen
könnte es reicht jetzt erst mal genug genug rum gebastelt was das angeht uninstall jetzt
bis 7 zipp es hat ja sicherlich einen grund warum ich 7 zipp nicht installiert hatte was
lock off each user sonst sonst ist noch geht gehts noch gehts noch windows ja sonst ist
alles alles klar noch ja
wollen wir dead space spielen im stream nicht aber ich habe das space fast das remake fast
durch aber ich habe schon tache oder ein zwei tage nicht mehr gespielt ich muss endlich
mal durchspielen jetzt also das remake ist wirklich gut geworden es gibt ein paar sachen
die mir nicht gefallen haben wir letzten schon darüber ausgelassen gut da hätten wir das
jetzt länglich besprochen länger als ich mir das ganze vorgestellt habe
ich bin wegen der neuen aber jetzt dabei mich in wie es wir einzuarbeiten das thema ist
echt komplex alles glaube ich dir das vr ökosystem ist wissenschaft für sich
sagst du das oder ist das von chat gpt also wslg von microsoft nutzt rdp anstatt einfach
den framework abzugreifen weil rdp eine erweiterte funktio moment das ist das
doch bestimmt einfach wieder gelogene chat gpt antwort oder das ist wieder irgendwelches
chat gpt tut so als wird die wahrheit erzählen ja das gut das ist ein nachteil es ist ja das
ist der nachteil gibt es immer wenn du windows als haus benutzt wobei ich sagen muss dass mit
updates ich hatte lange keine großartigen probleme mit updates mehr also am anfang von
windows 10 war es richtig schlimm als das ding nicht dann teilweise auch zwangs ausgeschaltet
hat oder so aber ich mache jetzt gefühlt einmal die woche irgendwie updates beim runterfahren
und es geht den architektur overview ja den kennen wir schon aber die frage ist doch warum
sie so gemacht haben ob das was mit multimonitor unterstützung zu tun hat kann schon sein ergibt
schon irgendwie sinn du hast gestern arch installiert und jetzt hast du kein netzwerk
mehr ging es denn bevor du ausgeschaltet hast also hast du auch schon das system gebootet
dass du kein network manager installiert muss jetzt von von hand network abmachen guck doch
mal ob der den netzwerk adapter überhaupt noch erkennt aber sogar jetzt werden der netzwerk
adapter ist ab oder ist dran dann wüsste ich jetzt so spontan auch nicht außer was du machen
kannst was manch was tatsächlich manchmal was bringt ist wenn du hier sagst falls du netzwerk
falls du netzwerk manager was tatsächlich manchmal was bringt ist wenn du sagst disabel networking
enable networking manchmal braucht man das ich weiß nicht warum selten aber manchmal braucht
man das macht es mal machen wir netzwerk aus und etwa wieder an oder gucken ob es geht das hat
da manchmal es liegt vielleicht an dhcp ich weiß es nicht genau ja ich weiß ich manchmal
manchmal spinnt das ein bisschen rum mit netzwerk manager ja das habe ich ja schon was zugesagt
ich glaube mittlerweile kann vmw ganz gut mehrere monitore unterstützen ich muss
dir aber sagen ich habe es noch nie ausprobiert oh sekunde ich sollte das vielleicht mal ich
sollte das vielleicht gerade mal wieder zurück stellen sonst wunder ich mich demnächst warum
warum ein vor allem er probleme hat ja sekunde muss man noch mal kurz dass ich es finde
aber wie ging das jetzt set affinity und wundere ich mich dass es irgendwie nicht richtig funktioniert
oder liegt daran jetzt kannst du aufhören mit benchmark was er ist eigentlich für den sub
was ihr das video genommen was kasse arduino mit neopixel ja dazu gibt es gute dazu gibt es gute
videos aber der hat es halt auch an den an den jumper kabeln dran weil das könnten sogar
ein bisschen dickere sein aber glaube glaube nicht da muss man halt echt gucken dass nicht
zu heiß wird richtig terminal transparent ok stimmt dazu wollte ich noch was sagen also
du brauchst einmal das hat ja schon jemand im chat gesagt du brauchst einmal irgendein
composite window manager der an sich transparenz unterstützt also zum beispiel so was wie p com
meine p com konfig so aus die ist sehr rudimentär das mit blur kannst du übrigens außen vor lassen
das hat das hat damit nichts zu tun das bräuchte ich glaube ich noch nicht mal an der stelle
dass das ist nur für also dass sie hinten transparent ist und den blur den habe ich
glaube ich mal für irgendein overlay getestet den habe ich mal für das für rofi getestet ob
sinnvoll ist den zu blören also das ist egal du brauchst auf jeden fall p com laufen und du
brauchst auch nichts einstellen großartig wichtig ist dass du laufen hast weil ansonsten geht das
nicht mit transparenz so und dann also guck wenn ich sage kill all um transparenz komplett weg
jetzt transparenz wieder da also du brauchst auf jeden fall ein composite manager wenn du
nicht i3 laufen hast und irgendwas anderes hast du wahrscheinlich schon eine nie gibt
kein neues update dazu so was du machen musst damit das funktioniert ist voll was du musst
in ein westerm gehen immer davon aus dass du auch westerm verwendest und dann musst du das
hier einstellen window background opacity man kann auch wenn noch background man kann auch
background images und so einstellen aber dass sie finde ich sie blöd aus und wenn du das
beispielsweise hier runter stellst dann ist es ziemlich transparent was aber kacke aussieht
da man den text nicht sieht und ich habe quasi nur 0,0 0,0 3 prozent transparenz und das passt
gerade passt gerade gut dass der pepo hinten bisschen durchschwimmert aber das termin auch
gut lesbar ist stimmt 3 prozent das geht ja von 0 bis 1 nicht 0,0 3 3 prozent 3 prozent
transparenz und das war es mehr musste mehr musst du soweit ich das in erinnerung habe
nicht einstellen post reverse video kursor ich habe keine ahnung was diese option macht aber
ich habe sie in meiner config datei stehen schein wichtig zu sein ja
gibt es gibt es noch nicht muss man fragen ob er da überhaupt was gemacht hat schon
ne auf win get habe ich gar kein bock
man muss schiff drücken damit man im kontext menü was kopieren kann ok wirklich das kenne
ich auch gar nicht properties details so wenn ich das jetzt kopieren will dann muss ich was
drücken shift nö bringen überhaupt nichts ich drücke ich drücke shift und jetzt habe ich
nicht kopiert jebaited chat im rechtsklickmenü da kann man einfach mit kontrol c ich will
doch nur den hinteren teil kopieren ich will doch nicht alles kopieren übrigens kontrol c geht
auch nicht habe ich gerade probiert guck kontrol c geht auch nicht kann man vor allem wir eigentlich
144 herz haben nein kann man nicht das ist tatsächlich eines der nervigst also der es
gibt zwei nervige punkte an vms der erste punkt ist dass sie kein 144 herz unterstützt
ist auch mit hacks und sonstigen sachen nicht möglich wird schon box das gleiche geht nicht
und der zweite punkt ist dass man keine gpu decoding kein gpu decoding für videos benutzen
kann das sind meine einzigen zwei größeren punkte die mich stören beim täglich benutzen
von der vm wo ich immer denke wieder denke hoffentlich klappt das mal ja sieht man auch
hier x rande 60 herz geht nicht das geht leider nicht das wäre sehr nice wenn das geht aber es
ist nicht möglich ich hoffe mal dass vm wer irgendwie da was macht weil es fühlt sich mit
120 herz plus einfach viel viel weicher alles an wieso willst du 144 herz in der vm wenn man
nicht in der vm zog zum beispiel fürs scrollen wenn ich die seite scroll hier guckt mal guckt
euch mal den vergleich an immer die seite hier und immer die seite hier moment sekunde auge
guck mal scroll mal die seite hier ok das ist im stream jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht richtig zu
sehen aber das scrollen hier fühlt sich so viel klarer an als dieses callen hier ja das
stream ist 48 herz ihr seht das nicht das ist das ist tatsächlich richtig doof dass es nicht
geht wir können mal kurz gucken verenden wir oder geht wird schon wird schon box 144
herz geht da vielleicht mittlerweile was wahrscheinlich nicht wahrscheinlich nicht wieso 48 weil es der
optimale kompromiss aus flüssigkeit und mitrate ist welchen vnc benutzt du gar kein ich benutze
für nichts vnc also meines wissens nach geht das geht das nicht mit ja so siehts aus ok
virtual box kann es auch nicht job leute nicht möglich wie es aktuell aussieht ich hoffe die
machen da mal was dran weil ganz ehrlich 120 plus also 120 herz plus monitore sind ja mittlerweile
kann man sagen standard kann man schon sagen standard ich würde fast sagen 120 herz plus
ist fast schon nicht ganz aber wahrscheinlich fast schon standard 2023
das warum ist eigentlich p7 zipp was anderes als 7 zipp muss man das muss man das verstehen
moment was habe ich denn da installiert überhaupt was ist denn 7 zipp was ist das moment gibt es
ok moment jetzt weiß ich auch warum die benchmark so unterschiedlich sind das
ist das ist komplett unterschiedliche software oder aber was ist das hier denn überhaupt
der lädt 7 zipp runter und patcht das so dass es auf linux läuft ne ne das ist was anderes der
lädt der lädt direkt 7 zipp ork runter und patcht das dann so dass es auf so dass es auf linux
läuft das ist alles mehr muss man nicht patchen dass es auf linux läuft ich glaube wir müssen
auch mal anderen aber dann habe ich immer noch nicht gecheckt dann habe ich immer noch nicht so
genau gecheckt was der unterschied jetzt ist war das der sommer ich habe es doch eben gefunden
ich hatte ich hatte es doch eben es hat doch auch jemand im chat gepostet ja ok das ist das
ist irgendein 7 zipp ork ok dann sind die benchmarks wirklich nicht so richtig vergleichbar
übrigens wir hatten das aktuelle installiert ok es gibt wohl irgendwie 7 zipp 7 zipp vor linux
7 zipp fork meine güte ist das wieder kompliziert ne nein das war ich nicht macht das eh nicht die
cpu allein nein die cpu alleine kann das nicht machen woher soll denn die cpu wissen auf welchem
quasi was laufen lassen soll ne das macht ein betriebssystem ist dafür zuständig das ist
übrigens auch genau der grund warum ich wenn aus 11 verwende weil der task scheduler also
der die cpu zeit verwaltet und tasks an kerne delegiert quasi wo es ausgeführt werden soll
also wo jetzt wie welche cpu zeit zur verfügung steht der kann erst seit wenn aus 11 die diese
ganze geschichte mit performance und efficiency course der winos 10 prozess und und cpu scheduler
kann das nicht deswegen habe ich wenn aus 11 genau das ist der grund warum ich wenn aus 11
habe der linux scheduler kann es schon lange aber das kann durchaus sein dass sie ein bisschen
durcheinander kommen weil ich ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher wie und was das ist dass das das
einteil der cpu zeit wie das funktioniert wie das verwaltet mit mit vmw also es war in der
vm läuft selbstverständlich der normale linux task und prozess und cpu scheduler aber unten
drunter muss ja noch irgendwas laufen was das irgendwie in einklang mit winos bringt ja keine
ahnung wie die das machen und es durchaus möglich dass es da probleme gibt und es eben nicht immer
auf performance course laufen sollte wenn es das macht wenn es wenn es das machen sollte da würde
ich mich nicht darauf verlassen dass das so klappt da sind zu viele zwischenstufen wo es probleme
geben kann
hast du virtualisierungs beschleunigung aus was ab hier ach meinst du hier ne ne das hat damit
nichts zu tun diese optionen hier sind für ganz andere sachen diese option ist dafür dass du
nestet virtualisierung machen kannst also indem es die diese diese virtualisierungs extensions
weiter weiter reicht das heißt du kannst dann in der vm weitere vms machen wenn du das einschaltest
ist das aber nicht unbedingt das was man oft braucht hier kannst du anderes zeug machen fragt
mich nicht deshalb mit performance nichts zu tun ich bin so weit hinten dran wenn es da
geschieht für den sub konzo mania dankeschön ich bin so weit hinten dran mit dem chat was ist
da los hecki danke für den sub max wie hast du damals mit den uns angefangen ich muss mal so
richtig hinter hinter steigen ist auch ein wort habe ich so oder nicht so richtig hinter steigen
weiß aber nie wo ich bei solchen dingen anfangen soll ich glaube ich kann dir nur den rat stark
geben wie bei den meisten anderen sachen wenn es um so was geht benutze es einfach benutze es also
es hat ja keinen sinn zu sagen ich will mich jetzt mit den jungs beschäftigen ich gucke
mir jetzt ganz viele tutorials webcasts und und lese sachen du musst es benutzen du musst
es benutzen und halt auch für nur ein bisschen kompliziertere sachen also wenn du jetzt einfach
nur der vm anschaltet um den browser aufzumachen dann wirst du wahrscheinlich nicht so viel lernen
also musst du es installieren du musst du musst es benutzen dann lernst du zum beispiel auch wenn
man pakete installiert dann lernst du ein bisschen umgang mit kommando zeilen einfach durch durch
benutzen aber du musst dann halt auch ein paar paar bisschen anspruchsvollere tasks drauf machen
als nur den browser aufmachen aber benutzt es benutzt es benutzt es zum browsing benutzt es
um dich auf server zu verbinden und alles mögliche du musst es nicht täglich also ich meine nicht
dass du dein windows de installieren sollst oder so machst dir in der vm und benutzt es einfach
ach so moment du redest ja tatsächlich also wenn du das ist trotzdem der würde ich dir
trotzdem empfehlen versuche also das beste ist wie du lernen wie du es lernst ist im täglichen
benutzen nachdem du jetzt ja nicht den ganzen tag per kommando zeile auf deine oracle vm drauf
bist und da wahrscheinlich auch nicht viel machst ja das meiste mit linux lernst du wirklich wenn
du linux täglich benutzt oder schließt die desktop benutzung mit ein macht in der vm sucht
dir irgendwie in den window manager raus den du den du gescheit benutzen kannst richtet
dir die vm ein allein schon also ohne mist solltest du es hinbekommen den archlinux zu
installieren mit der grafischen oberfläche so dass du das gut benutzen kannst dann hast du
schon sehr viel gelernt auf dem weg die installation von einem archlinux ist mit dem install script
mittlerweile einfach das heißt wenn du wenn du schon ein bisschen plan von linux hast kann ich
jetzt auf jeden fall empfehlen dann kriegst du eine archlinux installation ohne probleme hin easy mit
dem mit dem neuen archinstaller ist es überhaupt kein problem kann sie auch im zweifel den stream
angucken wo wir das wo wir das gemacht haben dann und dann richtet ihr wirklich mal mit einer
minimal install also wählen keine desktop umgebung aus oder so machen eine minimal installation dann
installierst du dir den x manjaro ja gut man manjaro kannst du auch nehmen aber ich würde
tatsächlich gleich in arch nehmen in minimal installation installierst den x installierst
den i3 oder in den desktop umgebung deiner wahl guckst dass es alles passt du wirst so viel
kommando zeile machen müssen wiki lesen müssen da hast du schon einiges gelernt durch durch
tägliches benutzen der kommando zeile lernst ja auch viel was du auf deinem server brauchst
also ich würde sagen einfach täglich benutzen ja das ist das das ist das beste was man machen
kann sowohl in der arbeit was administrativen der täglichkeit angeht als auch als auch auf
dem desktop gibt noch keine updates welchen stuhl benutzt du eigentlich ein in richtung
herrmann miller nö das würde mir damals im stream tatsächlich empfohlen ich muss euch
ehrlich sagen und ich höre auch von allen leuten dass sie immer super bequem sind aber
ich muss euch ehrlich sagen ich hatte immer so ein bisschen den eindruck dass es etwas
aufer hyped diese geschichte was ich für den stuhl benutze ist der hier in der mann
können die einfach alle mal dark themes machen please ich benutze den stuhl und er ist richtig
nice man weiße hintergründe alter ich muss schnell drüber scrollen man also der stuhl
ist cool was ich an dem stuhl mag bevor wir uns den preis angucken ich sage euch gleich
holt euch den stuhl nicht da ist unsinnig teuer aber für jemand wie mich der sein geld
damit verdient hier auf diesem stuhl zu sitzen sowohl privat als auch auf der aber also als
auch für die arbeit und und quasi halb privat ja stream ist ja nicht wirklich privat kann
man so nicht nennen also ich benutze den stuhl für private sachen vorm rechner ich benutze
den stuhl homeoffice zum arbeiten ich benutze den stuhl wenn ich wenn ich stream youtube
sachen mache also quasi professionell privat und semi professionell keine ahnung so und
was ich an dem stuhl wirklich mag sind mehrere sachen das erste ist ich versuche es euch
mal irgendwie zu demonstrieren aber ihr werdet wahrscheinlich nicht hören also ich ich lasse
mich jetzt gerade mal auf den stuhl drauf fallen und ich weiß ob man es im hintergrund
hört ich bin nicht der leichteste ich wiege aktuell irgendwie 92 kilo in dem dreh seitdem
ich hier meine abnehmen mein abnehmen stelz gemacht habe letztes jahr ich habe ja mal
108,5 gewogen ich habe es ungefähr 16 kilo abgenommen letzt jahr über und ich bin immer
noch ich bin immer noch ziemlich ziemlich dick was das angeht oh leute das mime board
ist abgekackt ach nee ich habe es zu gemacht ich kack noob ich habe es zu gemacht das wollte
ich eigentlich einplanen massif wie prophet so also was ich bei dem stuhl wirklich mag
ist man hört es ja glaube ich boom dass das ding ist mega stabil der stuhl ist ultra
stabil ja ich kann mich da drauf anlassen die federung ist immer noch super stabil
ich gucke mal wie oft habe ich schon geradet über windows und habe ja auf meinen armen
leben rumgeschlagen und sowas ich meine ich würde nicht sagen dass sie aussehen wie
neu aber auf jeden fall so als halten noch 20 jahre gleich geht es kaputt kaputt mein
dx racer habe ich kaputt gemacht dx racer habe ich genau das gleiche gemacht wie jetzt
habe mich quasi so in den stuhl fallen lassen und hat mich so abgestürzt mit den so also
ne moment nicht reinfallen stimmt gar nicht ich habe ich habe mich noch nicht mehr reinfallen
ich bin aufgestanden vom dx racer ich bin aufgestanden vom dx racer so richtig zack
so schnell und dann ist mir die armlehne aus dem rahmen rausgerissen das war nicht richtig
unten zusammengelötet bin ich halb aufs maul gefallen aus dem stuhl beim aufstehen ich
meine ich stelle mir vor ihr lehnt euch voll auf den armen drauf einmal bricht die armlehne
ab nie mehr dx racer leute nie wieder nie wieder kau ich mir sowas daraufhin habe ich daraufhin
habe ich mir den stuhl gekauft also wie gesagt ich mag annehmen dass der mega stabil ist
und auch den eindruck macht als geht er nicht von von ordentlich ordentlich die horror videos
wo die gasfedern explodieren echt die können explodieren das aber ganz schön laut oder
naja zumindest die zweite sache die ich an dem stuhl wirklich mag ist die sind die armlehnen
die wo sie irgendwie nicht in der lage sind hier gescheite bilder von zu machen hier sieht
man es also man kann die armlehnen nämlich hoch in der höhe verstellen nach vorn und
hinten verstellen und nach links und rechts verstellen das sind quasi 3d verstellbare
armlehnen und das ist sehr praktisch man denkt nicht dass man das braucht und ich habe mir
am anfang auch gedacht also ich kenne den stuhl schon länger oder schon bevor ich den
gekauft habe gekauft habe ich habe am anfang auch gesagt wer braucht denn sowas einfach
symmetrisch aber nee leute es ist wirklich praktisch also erstes erstes mal habe ich
die rechte armlehne ein paar millimeter höher eingestellt als die linke armlehne das park
finde ich einfach angenehmer weil rechts maus und links tastatur und ich sind es meistens
ein bisschen nach rechts rechts gedreht und ich habe beispielsweise auch die armlehne
hier rechts ein bisschen näher dran am körper wie links also es ist wirklich nicht schlecht
wenn man die armlehnen links rechts vorne hinten und so verstellen kann oben unten
also besser als man so denkt die zwei farten sachen finde ich nice die nackenstütze beziehungsweise
das kopfkissen braucht kein mensch ehrlich gesagt ich benutze es nicht ich das ist das
ist auch viel zu gerade dass man da überhaupt seinen kopf dran macht ich habe tatsächlich
ein kissen noch davor ich habe so ein kleines kissen mit mir zu einem gummiband dran das
habe ich jetzt ist gerade runter gerutscht das habe ich noch von meinem dx racer dx racer
kissen ja so ein ähnliches teil ist das ja so das habe ich ja sowas sowas in der richtung
genau so ein kissen habe ich hier oben noch drum sonst ist das nämlich viel zu weit hinten
und einfach nur nervig so und der rest ist dann auch cool du kannst einstellen wie schwer
gängig die rückenlehne ist du kannst komplett festmachen du kannst höhen verstellen du
kannst den abstand zwischen sitz und rückenlehne einstellen also eigentlich alles was du willst
ja also der stuhl ist wirklich super bequem und ein weiterer vorteil was ich auch gut
finde ist das ist jetzt kein stuhl der irgendwie damit beworben wird hier super atmungsaktiv
und sonst was aber ich schwitze da nicht drin man schwitzt nicht drin selbst im sommer wenn
es warm ist in ich schwitze in diesem stuhl schwitze ich nicht ich weiß nicht was die
dudes mit dem mit dem polster und dem stoff gemacht haben das ist wahrscheinlich auch
schon ein bisschen atmungsaktiv oder keine du schwitzt nicht drin also insgesamt bin
ich mit dem stuhl wirklich zufrieden empfehlen kann ich ihn trotzdem nicht zu kaufen weil
wenn beihadern wirklich não Evtp hier sieht sich ein bisschen besser compliance mit compassion
ich würde ihr wieder mit dem stuhl
schwitze in diesem stuhl mit dem post mit dem stuhl
okay das war's
es reviews
genau digitalnis
sommer
beachten umадцig
Deswegen kann ich nicht sagen ja Leute geht und holt euch ein weil die sind zu teuer aber
überlegt euch mal wenn ihr wenn ihr das so benutzt wie ich also ihr sitzt stunden täglich
davor ich sitze ja überlegt überlegt jetzt mal ernsthaft Leute überlegt euch das mal
ich stehe morgen sie morgens 7 uhr 30 auf so homeoffice bis sagen wir mal 16 uhr natürlich
sitze ich nicht den ganzen tag ich habe einen höhenverstellbaren schreibtisch ich laufe
hier auch mal rum ich gehe die treppe hoch und runter aber ich sitze den großteil von
7 uhr 30 bis 16 uhr auf diesem stuhl dann mache ich erstmal meine eineinhalb zwei stunden
lauf action draußen wann der action dass ich mich meine zwei stunden bewegt habe so
und dann sitz dann streame ich oder mache youtube zeug oder spiele irgendwas mmo kreisel
mit meinen kollegen da aus dem internet bis 22 23 uhr das heißt ich sitze auf diesem
scheiß ding am tag 16 stunden da nicht ganz ungefähr und dafür wenn man sich das überlegt
täglich 15 stunden ja täglich 15 stunden dafür kann man sich auch was gescheites kaufen
besser als rückenschmerzen zu haben
ja ich sitze mehr als ich im bett liege ja klar keine frage also kann man echt empfehlen
ordentlich was in den also in den ordentlichen stuhl zu investieren gerade wenn man das wie
gesagt auch professionell benutzt und damit geld verdient sehe ich überhaupt kein sich
überhaupt kein problem ich habe keine knienprobleme also ich muss eh sagen ohne mist auch wenn
ich jetzt 38 bin und man da vielleicht schon die ein oder andere probleme hat aber ich
habe keine probleme ich habe vor allem keine probleme mehr seit ich jetzt angefangen habe
seit seit einer ganzen zeit zwei stunden am tag mich zu bewegen also das mache ich ja
schon länger so richtig so richtig ausführlich zwei stunden am tag mache ich das erst seit
letztem jahr februar oder so aber seit einem jahr ungefähr ist auch die zeit also ich habe
quasi seit letztem jahr februar bis jetzt halt die 16 kilo abgenommen aktuell geht es
nicht weiter runter ich fresse auch ganz normal und es reicht jetzt nicht mehr die pure bewegung
dass es von alleine runter geht ja ich muss jetzt wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen trainieren
oder ein bisschen weniger futtern oder besseres zeug futtern dass es weiter weiter ordentlich
runter geht aber das reicht mir erst mal schon ja so jetzt aus und seitdem habe ich überhaupt
keine probleme mehr ich habe keine ich habe keine rückenschmerzen also gut wie keine
rückenschmerzen zu mal ein bisschen blöd bewegt hat ja jeder ich habe so gut wie keine
rückenschmerzen mehr ich habe so gut wie keine kopfschmerzen mehr ich habe ich hatte früher
teilweise probleme klingt jetzt klingt jetzt vielleicht klingt es ein bisschen nach gachi
bass aber ich hatte früher als ich mich nicht bewegt habe oder viel zu wenig bewegt
habe hatte ich oftmals probleme im im hinteren ich weiß ob ich weiß nicht ob ihr ob das jemand
von euch schon mal hatte und zwar so so entzündung am nerven im am nerven im arsch so dass es
komplett bis bis in die wade runter zieht wenn du auftritt kann ich euch sagen ist nicht
schön euch zieht von der arschbacke bis in die wade beim auftreten das sind so sachen
die will man nicht haben also das habe ich auch gar nicht mehr das habe ich also wie
gesagt mehr bewegung mache ich ja schon die letzten lange vor corona die letzten letzten
fünf vier fünf fünf jahre wahrscheinlich habe ich damit schon angefangen mich mehr
zu bewegen also mit täglich mit täglich laufen draußen bewegen aber so diese zwei
stunden wander action mache ich tatsächlich erst so ganz streng jeden tag durchziehen
außer sonntag mache ich das erst seit einem jahr aber seitdem ich das mache ja ich ja
schmerzen sowas in der richtung ist das genau hatte ich ich habe keine keine kreislaufprobleme
mehr und sonst was also ich kann es wirklich jedem nur ans ans ans herz legen ich hätte
mir das selbst nicht sagen lassen vor vor 10 15 jahren ja oder vor zehn jahren oder
vor fünf jahren noch also kurz bevor ich angefangen ich hätte mir das selbst nicht sagen lassen
hätte jemand erzählt so nach dem motto max alle deine probleme die du hast gehen weg
wenn du dich einfach ein bisschen bewegt samtag da hätte ich darauf geantwortet ich weiß
ich weiß ist ja nicht so als hätte ich das nicht gewusst ja ich hätte gesagt ich weiß
aber ich habe keinen bock als wenn er meine antwort drauf lässt mich in ruhe ich habe
keinen bock so aber nachdem ich jetzt mal angefangen hat muss ich sagen mir fehlt auch
was wenn ich mich meine eineinhalb zwei stunden am tag nicht ordentlich bewegt habe und es
ist doch sehr angenehm keine probleme zu haben also ich habe ich habe probleme aber ich meine
jetzt so körperliche probleme probleme habe ich sonst auch noch genug aber so körperliche
sein das ist schon sehr angenehm wenn man da einfach nix nix hat ich habe kreislaufmäßig
nix kopfwehen nix rücken sonst wie hinter nichts mehr einfach gar nichts mehr ich habe
nicht mehr so oft bauchschmerzen nach dem mittagessen und sowas da seht ihr mal wie das
alles miteinander zusammenhängt ich meine wie kann man sich das erklären dass zwei stunden
am tag bewegung dazu führen dass man weniger bauchwehen nach dem mittagessen hat und wohl
gemerkt ich bewege mich meistens danach erst richtig also so lang danach obwohl ich normalerweise
schon schon schon längst bauchschmerzen gehabt hätte aber das hängt alles irgendwie damit
zusammen auch wenn man es nicht glaubt und ich kann es jetzt natürlich auch nicht genau
erklären weil ich da keine keine ahnung von hintergrund infos hat aber bewegen ist ohne
scheiß dass eines der wichtigsten sachen die man machen kann und jeder jede minute bewegen
ist wichtiger als die davor wisst ihr also das wichtigste ist dass man erst mal überhaupt
sich ein paar meter bewegt anstatt nur rumzuocken eine viertel stunde ist um viel viel vielfaches
besser als gar nichts von einer viertel stunde auf eine halbe stunde bringt schon nicht mal
so viel wie die erste 15 minuten ist eine halbe stunde auch nicht viel ich glaube ihr
wisst was ich sagen will also jedes bisschen ist besser als gar nichts und ich wusste das
eigentlich auch schon immer ich wusste das davor auch schon immer aber ich habe gesagt
alter gehen wir nicht auf den sack also zu mir selbst gehen wir oder zu allen die was
erzählt geht man nicht auf den sack ich weiß aber ich habe keinen bock also ich kann es
wirklich nur jedem ans herz legen bewegt euch irgendwie eine stunde am tag ihr müsst ja
nicht zwei stunden zu eineinhalb zwei stunden da durch die berge wandern wie ich jeden tag
eine stunde stunde am tag ordentlich draußen bewegt danach kriegt ja auch noch ein bisschen
kriegt da kriegt ja auch noch ein bisschen vitamin d durch durch sonnenlicht und was
für auch nicht verkehrt leute ich habe mal vor jahren ein vitamin d normale werte oder
level war so ein test gemacht vitamin d so ab wann ist vitamin d mangel zentrum der gesundheit
genau wunderbar haben wir nicht einfach eine tabelle alter jetzt ist ja gut texte hier
tabelle ja hier ok vitamin d vitamin d punkt nett ernsthaft vitamin d hat eine eigene
webseite gibt es vielleicht auch so was bei wikipedia den traue ich mehr als vitamin d
punkt nett ist ja mal ok also ich hatte ja das hatte ich hatte acht acht nicht zehn
oder fünf zehn so acht und unter zwanzig ist mangel acht null weh also normal ist 35
bis 60 ich hatte acht was ist das nanogramm pro milliliter wahrscheinlich nanogramm pro
milliliter blut oder sowas also ich hatte acht ich hatte nix und ich habe vor weiteren
paar jahren mal ein machen lassen seitdem ich mich angefangen habe zu bewegen da war
das war schon deutlich war schon deutlich besser also lange rede kurzer sinn ich will euch
jetzt ja nichts einreden ihr könnt ja alle machen was ihr wollt jedes bisschen bewegung
ist besser als als gar keine bitte um bewertung der stelle ok aufgeht so hell bitte um bewertung
der stelle ok schauen wir uns das doch mal kurz aber wo alter wie lang ist denn die stellen
anzeige es hört ja gar nicht mehr auf ach ne ach ne hier geht es erst los ne das passt
schon hier geht es erst los moin twinko also zeige ich mal her ok das da oben brauchen
wir glaube ich nicht zu lesen komm ins team host host point wer ist host point wir sind
der größte web hosting anbieter der schweiz schweizer web hosting anbieter richtige heck
remans und bringen seit 22 jahren die entwicklung des internets in der schweiz ok bla bla bla
wer arbeitet bei host point egal ob system als host point als host pointer also lang der
nicht null werden kann ist ja alles gut bist du neugierig richtig ok bla bla bla bla wie
ist es ein host pointer zu sein bei uns bist du ok bla bla bla bla ok benefits benefits
flexibel arbeiten gestalte arbeitstage bewusste auch home office so wenn es deine tätigkeit
erlaubt wählst du das umfeld für deine aufgabe frei aus ortzeit ok das heißt ja auch ich
kann home office machen plus die sache ist halt die wer definiert das ob das meine tätigkeit
erlaubt vielleicht sagen die auch einfach ja also für das erstellen deiner für das
erstellen einer powerpoint präsentation das muss unbedingt vor ort erfolgen das geht
nicht von daheim reichlich freie zeit wir arbeiten 40 stunden in der woche ja gut
also 40 stunden die woche ist jetzt jetzt nicht unbedingt krass freizeit oder hältst
du uns fünf jahre die treue belohnen wir das ab dem sechsten jahr mit sechs wochen das
finde ich cool besser es ist besser als bei uns wo man irgendwie so eine einladung kriegt
zu irgendeinem komischen entertainment abend mit 30 anderen leuten die auch jubiläum haben
da gehe ich übrigens nicht hin ich habe ja die laden mich ja schon eine ganze weile ein
ich habe ja seit letztem jahr mein zehnjähriges jubiläum gehabt bei der firma wo ich jetzt
bin und ich habe das erste mal abgesagt jetzt wurde ich wieder eingeladen aber jetzt seit
ich gekündigt habe wurde ich nicht mehr eingeladen zum zehnjährigen jubiläum ich habe mich
davor gedrückt und ich dachte mir so ey komm du schaffst es schon auch dich zu drücken
bis du da weg bist und das hat tatsächlich geklappt jetzt werde ich nicht mehr eingeladen
lisch danke schön für den sub ab deinem zehnjahresjubiläum bekommst du jedes jahr
sogar acht wochen ferien jedes jahr jetzt wollen sie es aber wissen das ist natürlich
das ist natürlich nicht schlecht da muss aber auch erstmal zehnjahre da sein das ist natürlich
schon der hausnummer pauschaler flexi bonus aber ich meine es ist ein guter anreiz da
auch ein bisschen länger zu bleiben aber vielleicht machen sie ihre leute so fertig dass da keiner
zehnjahre bleiben will egal ob du im büro oder remote arbeitest hausnummer schützt
dich jährlich mit einem pauschalbetrag von 2000 schweizer freie das finde ich nicht
schlecht das schon mal nice moderne it ausstattung ok es ist schweiz ich kann zum thema schweiz
eh nicht viel sagen aber ich meine wir können es ja vergleichen mit dem was was hier so
geboten wird moderne it ausstattung alle mitarbeiter werden mit einem mobilen und modernen
arbeitsgerät ausgestattet heißt im endeffekt du kriegst notebook oder du kriegst ein smartphone
und notebook oder haben ein budget zur verfügung zusätzlich gibt es zwei desk ausstattung
für das büro und für zuhause weit screen monitore tastatur und maus ein swiss komm
abo gibt es auch dabei ok treibst du sport dann beteiligen wir uns mit 500 schweizer freien
pro Jahr für deine für sport treiben also kleine klasse finde ich gut das ist ja auch
nicht ganz uneigennützig also ich finde es gut dass sie es machen ja aber ich glaube
es haben viele arbeitgeber auch noch gar nicht realisiert dass es sich auch für sie sogar
auszahlen kann so was zu machen weil im ernst wenn ihr gerade wenn es ein it laden ist überlegt
euch mal wie viele leute probleme bekommen wenn sie mal 35 plus sind oder sagen wir
immer 35 plus 25 30 plus reicht da schon wenn du dein ganzes leben nur vom rechner gehockt
hast zum größten teil der tage auch und da kriegst du teilweise ab 25 plus schon schon
richtige probleme und wenn du ein bisschen sport machst sorgt es dafür du bist viel
weniger krank du bist wahrscheinlich wacher fitter motivierter also das zahlt sich unterm
strich für die wahrscheinlich sogar aus bildung ist uns wichtig familiengründung wenn du
mutter oder vater wirst bezahlt die hausbrenner lohnen während ans 14 ok gut da weiß ich
nicht wie sie in der schweiz aussieht ob das normal ist oder nicht sicher versichert ok
wirkste ne was wirk ich schön wirkerts wirk was auch immer möglich du möchtest noch
etwas länger workation soll das heißen jetzt habe ich ok workation du möchtest noch etwas
länger an deiner fairen destination verweilen und von dort arbeiten kein problem sofern es
die amazon sind viel grundsätzlich offen dafür ja da bin ich da wäre ich auch dabei
socializing das miteinander wird bei uns groß geschrieben wir veranstalten regelmäßig
social events arbeitgeber social events ich meine man muss ja nicht hingehen wenn man
nicht will ich mag sowas nicht zumindest nicht so übertrieben so nach dem motto wer
nicht hingeht ist doof mal ab und zu vorbeigucken mal hallo sagen so ab und zu wenn man eh noch
den kann man ja machen aber regelmäßig habe ich kein bock auf sowas
so
zusammen mit motivierten hochqualität ok bla bla bla ok jetzt gucken wir uns die eigentliche
stellenanzeige an hier systemadministrator systemadministratorin in linux die schweizer
bei denen hat sich das mit mwd noch nicht so durchgesetzt wobei kann man ja auch verstehen
männlich weiß deutsch geht ja in der schweiz so nicht das müsste dann mws heißen da bist
ja wieder ich dachte du bist gebannt ach nee das serious max hat sich vertan die schreibt
man mit anders gore da ist er ja ja ich habe ich habe bei uns mal gefragt wie es aussieht
im mod channel und die haben alle gemein ja da sage ich es da taugt den können wir modden
wobei du siehst es jetzt ja auch ja serious max inschreibt man mit anders gore nicht einfach
nur sarex 07 weil pass mal auf sarex falls du das falls du das hier warst sarex 07 wenn
ich null ich dachte das wärst du gewesen aber du bist ja der mit anders gore ach das
war wirklich dein alter channel oder was na gut vielleicht bist ja doch irgendwie so zweiter
channel oder komische dinger macht nur hier im stream sich zusammen reißt egal machen
alle leute irgendeinen irgendeinen mist haben alle schon mal mist gemacht ok also gucken
wir uns mal die stellenanzeigen an bewirb dich jetzt als größter web hosting anbieter
der schweiz bringen wir sein über das haben sie oben doch schon geschrieben bla bla bla
den rap es will ok das ist da wo die sind ok damit unsere service ist sicher müssen
wir die top moderne zuverlässige infrastructure als system administrat ist ein system administrator
im system operations team kommt das könnte auch wenn man ein bisschen mit schichtbetrieb
und support je nachdem wie sie es auslegen kümmerst du dich um einen sicheren ein betrieb
unsere Infrastruktur. Okay, das gehört zu den Aufgaben. Pflege, Erneuerung, Mithilfe
bei der Weiterentwicklung unserer Infrastruktur wie den WebDB oder Mail-Clustern, den Arbeitsgeräten,
was den Arbeitsgeräten? Hä? Wie passt das denn da rein? Den WebDB, Mail-Cluster, den
Arbeitsgeräten? Den Multimedia-Installation in vielen weiteren Komponenten. Mit Arbeitsgeräten
meinen die Notebooks der Mitarbeiter oder wie? Das sind doch zwei komplett unterschiedliche
Paar Schuhe. Planung, Koordination und Durchführung von Deployments sowie Betrieb und Management
von Servern und Diensten. Okay. Software und Systempflege, mein Deployment kann man sich
jetzt drüber streiten, ob das ein Admin macht, aber es ist Auslegungssache. Warum nicht?
Spricht ja nichts dagegen, dass das ein Admin macht. Software und Systempflege von Konfigurationsmanagement,
ja das ist heutzutage so. Über den Rollout bis hin zur Reaktion auf Fehlern, Debugging
und Fehlermemung und Eskalation. Okay. Unterstützung des 2nd Level Supports bei Anspruchsverfahren.
Moment, man selbst ist 1st Level oder ist man quasi 3rd Level und unterstützt 2nd Level
oder ist man einfach nur normaler Admin und hilft dem Support ab und zu, wenn sie nicht
weiterkommen? Ne, ich glaube das steht einfach nur da, dass man eben die auch unterstützt.
Das ist aber eigentlich nix, was ich in die Anzeige reinschreiben würde, weil das man
Leute die Hilfe braucht unterstützt, sehe ich jetzt nicht als so abwegig an. Egal. Du
kriegst mit Abschluss in Informatik. Okay. Oder versierter Selfmade Unix. Hacker-Man.
Rundiertes Know-How im Bereich Unix und Internet. Große Neugier, Freude an der Technik und Leidenschaft
Dinge zu verstehen. Erfahr immer mit Shells und Skript-Sprachen und Vorteil. Okay, logisch.
Ein ordentlicher Admin hat natürlich auch Ahnung von ein paar Programmiersprachen. Weiß
ich jetzt nicht, dass er hier die krassesten Anwendungen in ein paar Minuten aus dem Ärmel
schüttelt, aber neben Bash, also jeder Admin sollte ordentliche Bash-Skript auf die Reihe
bekommen, aber auch so ein paar andere Sachen nebenbei sind nur von Vorteil, wie sie schreiben,
nur von Vorteil, wenn man da ein bisschen Durchblick hat. Was umfasst Unix alles? Ja,
das muss man die fragen. Ich gehe mal davon aus, sie meinen Linux, ich gehe nicht davon
aus, dass sie BSD verwenden, wobei es ein Internetprovider ist, oder? Könnte auch BSD sein. Aber, aber
ich, oh Gott Leute, hör doch mal auf rumzuspammen mit so einem Scheiß immer, man. Was ist denn
das hier? Meinst du allen Ernst, dass irgendjemand geht jetzt auf deinen Channel, nur weil du
es hier gespammt hast, oder was? Ah, Gott. Modgis. Jawoll, Sarix, sehr gut. Du kannst
die Follower auch nicht schon wieder ausmachen. Erster Bann, so gehört sich das, genau. Ähm.
So, wir stehen geblieben. Ja. Was mir da fehlt ist, mich würde ein bisschen die Details interessieren,
da stehen ja eigentlich gar keine Details drin. Das Einzige, was da an Details drin
geschützt sind Web, DB und Mailcluster, aber das ist ja auch ziemlich nichts sagend. Du
musst für die Uni Cobol lernen, willst du mich, debatest du mich jetzt? Ihr macht doch
nicht ernsthaft Cobol an der Uni, oder? Ach, hier sieht man auch, was sie, doch, na dann
spiel Spaß. Hier sieht man auch, was sie verwenden. Linux, Docker, okay, ist doch, ist doch ein
BSD. Sitze mal da. Hätte ich, hätte ich gar nicht gedacht. Tatsächlich BSD. Okay, der
Rest der OpenSSH muss man ja wirklich nicht aufführen. Der Rest ist ziemlich Standard.
NetApp, gut was Storage angeht, ist das ja auch recht, recht schön. Okay, OpenStack
ist auf jeden Fall nicht Standard und NetApp ist auch nicht wirklich. Also mit Standard
meine ich jetzt, dass es die meisten Leute wissen und kennen. Standard ist es schon irgendwie,
das ist alles verbreitetes Zeug. OpenStack ist tatsächlich nicht so ohne, habe ich beispielsweise
gar keinen Plan von. Aber es wäre trotzdem sinnvoll da ein bisschen mehr reinzuschreiben,
was sie eigentlich haben wollen. Ja, klingt doch gar nicht schlecht. Guck mal, kann sogar
80% arbeiten. Ja. Hey, wenn die noch jemand brauchen, Schweizer Gehalt würde ich auch
nehmen, wenn ich einfach nur immer von Deutschland aus arbeiten könnte. Nee, nee, Leute, ich
suche nichts. Ich habe ab 1. April was Neues. Das mache ich auch erst mal jetzt. Oder fällt
mir ein, ich muss da noch Unterlagen hinschicken. Aber ich habe ja Zeit bis drei Wochen bevor
es losgeht. Arbeitest du mit Proxmox? Nö. Wir haben fast ausschließlich. Oh, vor allem
mehr auf der Arbeit und privat, privat habe ich auch kein Proxmox. Nee, ich habe das schon
beim, ich habe damit schon immer ein bisschen rumgespielt, aber nicht, dass ich große Ahnung
hätte von. Aber alles, was ich gesehen habe, war recht straight forward ehrlich gesagt.
Etten wir das auch. Ich muss mal gucken, ob ich irgendwie mit dem Chat noch durchkomme.
Welchen VNC benutzt du gar keinen? Müsste sein, ist doch ganz einfach. Leute, warum
habe ich nur 4900 Bitrate? Das liegt dann einfach daran, weil es immer noch viele Leute
gibt, die den Stream gucken wollen, die den Kack-Internen-Anschluss haben oder vielleicht
nochmal ein Video oder irgendwas nebenbei laufen lassen wollen und dann bekommen sie Probleme.
Deswegen habe ich 4900 und für das, was ich hier mache, so Desktop Übertragung, reicht
es ja voll und ganz. Da würde sogar noch weniger ausreichen. Aber ich finde, es ist
der beste Kompromiss, wenn auch mal ein bisschen was passiert, gescrollt wird 48 FPS, 4000
Euro Bitrate. Bester Kompromiss aus flüssiger Stream und gute, gute Bildqualität.
Was ist das? Eben war ich doch noch hier unten. Warum ist es jetzt so? Ich habe gedacht, ich
bin fast durch mit dem Chat. The fuck? Gibt es eigentlich einen Performance Unterschied
zwischen Vm und VirtualBox? Also wenn es um grafische Sachen geht, ist Vm ja meilenweit
vorne. CPU-technisch nimmt es sich nicht viel. Du könntest den ganzen Abend essen, ja mach
doch. Wo ist das Problem? Das hatten wir schon. Du wolltest Atomic Heart zocken, was ist denn
Atomic Heart für ein Game? Taugt das? FPS Action Rollenspiel? Halt gute Bewertung.
Ist das Singleplayer oder Multiplayer? Russisches Bioshock?
You can't skip 6 hours. Singleplayer. Klingt tatsächlich ganz interessant.
Ich schreibe mir das mal auf, vielleicht gucke ich mir das auch mal an. Also nicht im Stream,
aber ich bin ja eher auf der Suche aktuell, wo ich ein bisschen was spielen kann. Gibt
ja wenig Games, die mich ansprechen. Max, was ist deine Meinung zu MS Intune und
Asher? Also zu MS Intune kann ich nichts sagen, aber Asher verwenden wir hauptsächlich auf
diese Arbeit. Und Asher ist auch der Cloud-Anbieter, mit dem ich mich am besten auskenne. Ich
finde Asher nicht schlecht. Man muss sagen, ich habe schon ein bisschen Google Cloud gemacht,
aber mit Abstand am wenigsten AWS gemacht. Bei AWS triggert mich immer, dass die Sachen
so unklar benannt sind. Ist irgendwo bei Asher auch so. Was mich bei Asher ein bisschen
nervt ist, übrigens von den Web-Interfaces muss ich sagen, gefällt mir Asher mit Abstand
am besten. Versus die anderen zwei. Man macht ja nicht unbedingt so vieles über das Web-Interface,
aber gerade wenn man so ein bisschen discovert, was es so alles gibt, was man machen kann,
dann nimmt man noch das Web-Interface. Also ich persönlich finde das Asher Web-Interface
am besten, wenn es auch extrem bloated und oversized ist. Also das ist ja vollgestopft
mit allem Möglichen. Möglich viel finden tut man da nicht. Ich finde trotzdem, dass
das Web-Interface am besten ist von Asher. Und ansonsten, Asher kann halt alles irgendwo.
Von Kubernetes bis Web-Apps, Edge, Hosting, Zeug, Redundante, Datenbank-Sachen, Skalierung,
also alles was du dir im Cloud-Umfeld überlegen kannst, kannst du wahrscheinlich mit irgendeinem
Asher-Dienst machen. Aber wobei, okay, das ist nicht alles, aber sehr vieles. Alles
nicht. Aber trotzdem, das ist für mich immer noch die angenehmste Cloud-Plattform. Wahrscheinlich
weil ich mich mit der auch am besten auskenne. Also Asher ist top, einiges muss man halt
aufpassen, kann auch zur Kostenfalle werden. Cloud muss nicht zwangsläufig immer billiger
sein. So MS-Intune kann ich nichts sagen. Endpunktverwaltung. Aha. Können wir nicht.
Ist das so ein Remote-Desktop? Ja, die Stühle sind richtig nice.
Warum braucht man Stühle mit Software? Das irritiert mich jetzt. Das kann sein, dass
die keine gescheite Software programmieren können, aber die Stühle sind gut. Bist du
einer dieser hippen Stehschreibtisch-Typen? Naja, wenn ein Stehschreibtisch hip ist, dann
schon. Ich benutze den leider viel zu selten, obwohl ich einen höhenverstellbaren Schreibtisch
habe, aber manchmal ist er ganz praktisch. Deswegen ist es ganz gut, wenn man zwischendurch
ein bisschen rumläuft. Laufen fördert die Darmtätigkeit, so so. Ja gut, ich weiß, ich
weiß. Das merkt man ja so nach dem Motto Verdauungsspaziergang-mäßig. Wie viele Kilometer
läufst du ungefähr? Moment. Moment. Health. Health. Was sagt ein Apple dazu? 13.838 Steps.
Okay. Und wie viele ist das jetzt? Gibt es das vielleicht auch in ordentlichen Zahlen?
Also das ist heute. Das ist heute. Insgesamt. Heute insgesamt. Gibt es das da vielleicht
in Kilometern oder so? Das kann man sich doch. Okay, keine Ahnung. Ich bin zu blöd, diese
Health-App zu bedienen. Sind ziemlich glatt 10 Kilometer. Ja, könnte schon sein. Es müssten.
Es müssten mehr als 10 Kilometer sein. Es müssten. Es müssten mehr als 10 Kilometer
sein, weil. Ich bin heute eine große Runde gelaufen. Vom Bahnhof Heim. Also über den
Brücke am Main lang. Und ich weiß, dass die Runde schon knapp 10 Kilometer ist. Und ich
bin ja davor noch gelaufen. Morgens ein Stück zum Bahnhof. Dann in Frankfurt vom Bahnhof
zum Büro. Vom Büro in Frankfurt zurück. Das müsste eigentlich eher was um 12 Kilometer
sein. Weil das ist ja der komplette Tag da drin. Und ich bin auf dabei noch ein bisschen
rumgelaufen. Also eher 12 Kilometer, würde ich sagen. Hattest du immer dein Handy dabei?
Ja, auf den längeren Strecken. Ja, im Büro vielleicht nicht, aber sonst ja. Das ist ein
weiterer Pluspunkt von Homeoffice. Wenn man nämlich beim Homeoffice fertig arbeiten ist,
ist man direkt daheim und kann dann erst mal eineinhalb Stunden, zwei Stunden ein bisschen
Sport machen. Und man hat immer noch Zeit für Streaming, für MMO-Kreiselgrind, für
alles, was man machen will. Imperial, danke für den Sub. Bin aktuell Windows-Admin. Du
hast letztens gesagt, die suchen bereits Leute ohne Linux-Skills, da es einfach zu wenig
gibt. Vielleicht kann man ja mit so einer Administrator-Stelle ins Linux-Game reinkommen.
Naja, also wenn die explizit einen Linux-Administrator suchen, dann werden die meisten Leute auch
Leute mit Linux-Erfahrungen suchen. Ja, es ist so, dass die Arbeitgeber aktuell die Ansprüche
schon ganz schön runterschrauben müssen, weil es zu wenig Leute im IT-Umfeld gibt.
Und das finde ich auch eine gute Sache, weil gute IT-Leute zeichnen sich hauptsächlich
auch dadurch aus, dass sie es schaffen, in kurzer Zeit sich in was einzuarbeiten. Allerdings
muss man natürlich sagen, es kommt immer auf den Umfang und die Größe des Themengebiets
an. Und wenn die jetzt jemand haben wollen, der direkt einsteigt und dann auch schon administrative
Linux-Tasks in einer produktiven, in einem produktiven Environment zu machen, dann werden
die wahrscheinlich keinen Windows-Admin einstellen, der gar keine Erfahrung mit Linux hat. Wenn
du jetzt als Windows-Admin arbeitest, aber auch Ahnung von Linux hast, dann sieht das
wieder anders aus. Aber wenn du gar keine Ahnung von Linux hast und erst da versuchst
reinzukommen, das weiß ich nicht, wenn sie explizit eine Linux-Admin suchen, ob sie sich
darauf einlassen. Möglich ist es, möglich ist das, vor allem wenn du schon ein bisschen
eigene Initiative gezeigt hast und vielleicht doch nicht komplett blutige Anfänger bist,
möglich ist das, die suchen halt wirklich wie verrückt Leute gerade. Es kann durchaus
sein, dass sie sich darauf einlassen. Und das stimmt, letztendlich musst du einfach
Linux verwenden. Vor allem warum willst du überhaupt Linux-Admin werden, wenn du Windows-Admin
bist und keine Ahnung von Linux hast. Vielleicht geht dir ja Linux so sehr auf den Sack wie
mir Windows. Und dann willst du es auch nicht machen. Okay, BlueSky sagt, ich habe gestern
viel über, was? Führungsfeind. Leute, wisst ihr, ohne Scheiß wisst ihr, was ich gerade
gelesen habe? Wo ich gedacht habe, was schreibt ihr da? Ich habe gelesen, Einführungscreme.
Das Wort gibt es zwar nicht, aber mein Gehirn hat aus diesem gerade Einführungscreme gemacht.
Hyper Gatschi. Ich habe gestern viel über Führungsverhalten nachgedacht und komme zu
dem Schluss, dass du eigentlich als Leistungsträger in einer Schlüsselposition bist und durch
Disillusionierung deiner Motivation beraubt wurdest. Schade, dass Führung in Deutschland
so scheiße ist. Okay, ich habe mir da jetzt doch nicht so tiefgreifend Gedanken darüber
gemacht, ob ich zum gleichen Schluss kommen würde. Ich bin mir jetzt auch nicht sicher,
ob du mich meinst, also Max, ob du mich meinst oder ob du das so allgemein schreibst für
Leute, die keinen Bock mehr haben oder vielleicht sogar auf dich selbst bezogen. Also ich glaube
aber, dass das schon ganz gut hinkommt, dass man halt oder ich glaube es betrifft
ja auch viele, dass man nach einer gewissen Zeit einfach merkt, wenn hinter dem großen
Gelaber nichts dahinter ist. Das ist ja im Prinzip Disillusionierung. Du gehst da mit
großer Erwartung ran und lässt dich vielleicht auch am Anfang noch ein bisschen beschwätzen,
aber mit der Zeit stellst du fest, hinter dem ganzen Geschwätze steckt ja eigentlich
gar nichts dahinter und dann wird gesagt, ah jetzt machen wir es aber richtig und dann
lernst du, ah es wird wieder nicht richtig gemacht, aber jetzt aber wieder nicht und
dann wirst du immer immer desillusioniert. Ja, das stimmt schon. Das ist aber ein Thema,
da kann ich extrem viel darüber erzählen und ich muss jetzt gleich Leute, was ist jetzt?
Ihr wisst es auch, gleich ist Bedgetime. Wie häufig bist du jetzt im Büro? Also ich soll
zwei Tage die Woche da sein, 50 Prozent, was ja auch der Hauptgrund schlechthin war, warum
ich mir einen neuen Job gesucht habe. Die Sache ist jetzt bloß die. Ich habe gekündigt
im Dezember. Ich habe eh schon nicht mehr so krass viel Motivation und wisst ihr, was
ich jetzt einfach mache? Ich gehe einfach nur noch einen Tag hin und gucke, ob sich
jemand beschwert, aber es wird sich keiner beschweren, weil ich in knapp einem Monat
eh weg bin. Ja, die gab es schon. Kann ich, musst du mich morgen fragen, kann ich morgen
was zu erzählen? Ich weiß nicht, was die Leute sich denken. Denkt wirklich irgendjemand,
der geht in den Channel und spamt dann da rum? Oder gehen die Leute wirklich da hin und gucken
sie sich den Scheiß an? Also ich benutze Docker täglich, ich bin mir nicht sicher,
ob ich schon Version 23 habe, aber müsste ich haben, weil Arch, by the way. Könntest
du mir vielleicht trotzdem sagen, wie du das verwendet hast? Guck dir im Archiv den Cobalt
Stream an. Geh ins Archiv, suche nach Cobalt oder da ist es doch bestimmt drin. Archiv,
Cobalt. Ja. Guck dir an, wie ich mit Comic Sans Cobalt programmiert habe und es nicht
funktioniert hat. Ist BSD schlecht veraltet? Nö. Überhaupt nicht, das ist genauso aktuell
wie Linux wird immer noch. Also gibt es ja mehrere. Bei BSD ist es ein bisschen so, da
gibt es auch, nennen wir es mal mehrere Distributionen, mehrere verschiedene BSD. Free BSD, Open BSD,
Dragonfly BSD. Was gibt es noch? Was ist BSD? BSD ist glaube ich, wenn ich es aus dem Kopf
hinkriege die Berkley Software Distribution. Das ist eine Unix Variante. Was haben wir sonst
noch? Open BSD, Free BSD. Ich glaube da noch ein großes BSD. Berkley Software Distribution,
BSD, Open BSD, Free BSD, Net BSD gab es glaube ich noch. Genau und Dragonfly, das habe ich
mir gedacht. Dragonfly BSD, weiß gar nicht ob es das überhaupt noch gibt. Gibt es das
noch? Dragonfly BSD. Gento ist auch BSD, ne. Da noch aktuell. Ungewöhnlich, ja. Gar
nicht so ungewöhnlich, weil was die meisten Leute nicht wissen, die Playstation läuft
auf BSD Basis. Also wenn es danach geht, ist BSD total normal. Für viele Leute. Aber natürlich
bekommt man bei der Playstation es nicht mit, dass es auf BSD Basis ist. Damit interagiert
man ja nicht. Aber ich kann es euch sagen, also wenn ich es mir nicht glaubt Leute, hier,
Playstation BSD. BSD. Hat die Playstation 3 auch schon gemacht und wahrscheinlich auch
die PS2. Was die PS1 hatte, keine Ahnung. Vielleicht auch BSD. Kann man bedenkenlos
Firmware Keys per Key Resellern kaufen. Ja kannst du. Moment. 110? 110? Ist das ein
neuer? Serious Max? Ist das ein neuer? Ist neu! Poggers! Jawoll! Turnschuh Admin habe
ich früher gemacht. Da war ich auch noch eine ganze Ecke dünner. Da habe ich noch in unseren
Technikräumen an den Switchen vorbeigepasst, ohne Kabel raus zu reißen mit meinem Bauch.
Gut, heute gibt es diese Technikräume nicht mehr. Aber heute, also früher haben die den
Felix und mich, mit dem Felix habe ich auch mal zur Gamescom glaube ich ein Video aufgenommen.
Früher haben die bei uns, also als ich noch beim Provider gearbeitet habe, da haben die
immer den Felix und mich in so ganz kleine Mini-Technikräume geschickt, weil wir die
einzigsten zwei waren, die dünn genug waren, um an den Switchen vorbeizustellen, also die
Räume waren wirklich mini und es hängen alles voller Switche, weil wir die einzigen waren,
die an den Switchen vorbeigekommen sind, ohne halt mit dem Bauch vorne die Kabel versehentlich
zu beschädigen oder raus zu reißen. Heute wird es auf jeden Fall eng werden. Ich meine
mittlerweile nach dem Abnehmen komme ich vielleicht mit sehr viel Bauchreinziehen wieder durch.
Aber damals war das easy. Ja genau, das habe ich mir auch gedacht. Beim neuen Arbeitgeber
ist die Homeoffice-Regelung ein Tag die Woche bzw. nach Absprache alle 14 Tage. Also da
bin ich dabei. Wie heißt das Stream, wo du deinen Arch installiert hast? Irgendwas mit
der Suche? Die Suche ist ja wirklich gut gemacht. Nagios? Nagios mag ich auch. Nagios ist jetzt
ja nicht so wirklich das, was man heutzutage als neues System aufbaut, aber Nagios mag
ich auch. Ich habe auch jahrelang, auch noch teils während der Ausbildung, habe ich Nagios,
große Nagios Installationen betreut und mit eingerichtet. Ich habe immer noch ein Herz
für Nagios. Ja, Azure ist top, da kann man nichts sagen. Also ich mag Azure. Man hat
von abgesehen, dass es von Microsoft ist, aber es ist ok. Es ist nicht mit Windows Abfakt
zu vergleichen. Was hast du für eine Ausbildung gemacht? Ich habe Fachinformatiker für Systemintegration
gelernt. Vor über 15 Jahren. Wieso kopierst du ein M? Die Frage ist eher, warum kopierst
du kein M? Ich glaube eines der Hauptpunkte bei BSD und warum Sony das verwenden dürfte
auch die Lizenz sein. Vermute ich einfach mal. Ich glaube die BSD Lizenz ist großzügiger
als Linux. Also bei Linux ist es ja so, dass du teilweise dein Source Code irgendwie mit
veröffentlicht hast. Ich glaube bei BSD ist das noch nicht mal der Fall. Ich glaube BSD
ist, wenn du so willst, noch freier von der Lizenz, Herr Altenlinux. Ah, zieh, Dankeschön
für den Sub. Auch, wir hatten teilweise Technikräume, da musste man ganz schön teilweise auch laufen
im Treppenhaus. Und ok, erzähl ich jetzt nicht, aber ich habe euch ja schon erzählt von unseren
Einsätzen auch mit Untertischen rumkrabbeln und sowas, wo ich den Schock fürs Leben bekommen
habe in meiner Ausbildung. Das habe ich euch ja schon mal erzählt. Wenn nicht, erzähl
ich das nächste Mal vielleicht nochmal. Ich muss jetzt gleich ins Bett. Doch, kann man.
Der ist nicht da gewesen heute. Ok, also Leute, wir sehen uns morgen im Stream, höchstwahrscheinlich,
vielleicht muss ich auch MMO Kreiselcraft machen. Wir sehen uns, machts gut, bis denn,
tschüss.